[musique] Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement Paul ? Euh
Paul Morera, je fais du documentaire
pour principalement la télévision,
quelques plateformes comme Netflix et
euh on dit de moi que je fais du
documentaire d'investigation, même si je
me demande encore ce que ça signifie.
Eddoui
Eddou Plenel, je suis journaliste depuis
bientôt 1 demi-siècle et je suis
cfondateur et président de Media Part.
Un petit whisky euh
toujours volontiers mais je le vois pas
là. Juste un doigt euh
Ah
avec modération
avant ou après l'interview ?
Pendant que vous voulez. [rires] Voilà.
Messieurs, nous vous recevons ce soir
pour
parler de votre profession, parler soit
des qualités, soit du malaise, soit des
problèmes que vous rencontrez, des
dangers que vous pouvez affronter, des
gens qui vous font des crocheptes, des
gens qui vous passent au mixeur ou des
gens qui font grosse pression pour
éviter de sortir des choses.
Euh, on va donner la parole à Paul. La
première question que je vais vous poser
et ce sera la même pour les Oui, je vais
demander de vous faire commence le le
l'interview sur l'autocritique de votre
profession.
Waouh, je suis pas préparé là. Euh
l'autocritique de ma profession, mais
aurait il y aurait vraiment tellement de
choses à dire.
Moi, en tant que documentariste, je
pense que on porte une petite
responsabilité dans l'installation
du
euh du journalisme d'opinion.
Au sens, quand je dis journalisme
d'opinion, c'est le plateau, hein, je
parle de télévision là parce qu'on va on
va essayer de rester dans son champ de
compéten parce qu'il y a un moment on a
porté ce discours de l'objectivité
n'existe pas. L'objectivité n'existe
pas. en revendiquant une subjectivité,
ce qui est tout à fait légitime, mais il
y a un moment où quand tu dis
l'objectivité n'existe pas, tu dis la
vérité n'existe pas. Et en fait, tu
c'est la porte ouverte à effectivement
que ce soit substitué par
des conversations de football. Moi
j'adore les convers les angueulades de
football, je trouve ça formidable. Mais
le concept de l'engueulade de football,
s'était tendu absolument à tout, à la
politique internationale, à la politique
intérieure, au sociétal. C'est devenu un
modèle économique pour les chaînes tout
info et ça a permis à cause de cette
espèce de subjectivité euh euh exacerbé
euh l'installation en gros de d'une
sorte de spectacle de la fake news
permanente sur certains plateaux de
télévision toute info.
Lesquels ?
Moi moi je pense à ces news. On va on va
pas on va pas faire comme si on n'allait
pas nommer les gens. Je pense qu'il y a
un vrai problème. Certains plateaux, moi
je regarde assez peu. Donc en fait, j'en
ai les embrins un peu quand quand je
suis sur Twitter, je vois les en fait
les morceaux choisi et je me dis "Mais
c'est en fait c'est du Fox quoi. C'est
du Fox News." Et je me souviens quand
j'allais aux États-Unis il y a longtemps
y a il y a 15 ans quand Fox News
commençait à faire très fort, j'étais
littéralement fasciné mais vraiment
comme la mangoue et le serpent quoi. Je
j'étais je regardais cette télévision et
je me disais
"Cô serpent ou côté mangoue ?" Je dirais
côté serpent.
[rires]
Mais euh enfin, je trouvais ça fascinant
parce que c'était un lieu où je me
rappelle d'un type qui s'appelait Gary
Web. Tous les soirs, Gary Web dans une
une mise en scène qui ressemblait un peu
à à qui veut gagner des millions hein
avec les lumières bleues, de la musique
qui fait peur et tout, il expliquait la
même chose qu'il y avait un complot des
islamistes pour prendre le pouvoir aux
États-Unis lié à Soros. Enfin, il
faisait il avait un tableau noir comme à
l'école et il faisait un grand schéma et
le mec était cinglé. Cinglé. C'était le
fameux la fameuse théorie du grand
remplacement qui aujourd'hui a atterri
est en plein milieu de la table en
France. Et c'est vrai que quand tu l'as
vu grandir aux États-Unis porté par un
type comme Gary Web qui dira des années
plus tard qu'il prenait des médicaments
et que ça lui faisait ça lui a fait
beaucoup de mal à la tête et quand il se
revoyait, il se disait "Mais qu'est-ce
qui m'est arrivé quoi Enfin, je il a
fait lui-même son autocritique. Bon,
voilà, ça c'est euh je pense que il y a
un moment où euh notre profession doit
les journalistes en tout cas doivent
mettre au centre de tout la recherche de
l'objectivité. Ce qui veut pas dire la
neutralité. C'est ça qui est
intéressant, c'est que on on doit être
objectif et pas neutre. Et Louis
Paul a entièrement raison. Ce qui menace
aujourd'hui le journalisme, c'est ce
règne des opinions,
l'autocritique.
Oui, mais nous sommes journalistes, donc
c'est du journalisme dont on parle.
C'est un champ de bataille et on y mène
des batailles. Et en l'occurrence
ce règne des opinions, c'est la mort de
l'information. Le journalisme, c'est un
rapport à la vérité de fête. On peut ne
pas aimer un journaliste par préjugé,
pour ce qu'il dit, pour ce qu'il pense,
pour sa gueule, pour j'en sais rien.
Voilà. pour sa voix qui tremble par
exemple. Euh
pas la voix qui tremble ce soir.
Non mais non mais je l'ai pas. [rires]
C'est c'est ce qu'on appelle les
diffamations nécessaires chez dans le
métier d'avocat. C'est du pont morétique
qui a dû lui glisser ça. [grognement]
Voilà comme il avait fait il y a un an
et quel face à une révélation de
médiapart. Il est chez Bourdin et on lui
dit "Mais médiapart et Penel, ils vous
en veulent ?" Il répond Hervé Plenel.
C'est c'est une vieille technique. Je
m'appelle dans l'état civil Hervé Edoui
Olivier Pleinel. Mais je me suis
toujours appelé Edoui simplement. Edoui
n'est pas un saint, n'était pas dans un
calendrier. Donc quand on m'a
enregistré, il a fallu rajouter un
prénom. Bref, on jette le soupçon. Vous
voyez ce mec qui se cache et tout. J'en
reviens. Ce règne des opinions, c'est la
guerre de tous contre tous. C'est mon
identité contre ton identité, mon
origine contre et cetera. C'est ce monde
du clash. Et là où vient l'autocritique,
c'est comment le journalisme a pu être
corrompu par le divertissement.
Il y a pas que
les effets de cours.
Oui, mais j'y viens, j'y viens. Le
divertissement déjà, le divertissement
comme technique, comme technique
d'audience, comme technique.
Vous parlez d'autocritique ? Bah oui,
moi j'ai été à ces émissions. J'ai
accepté d'aller dans ces sortes d'arènes
me disant je vais pouvoir glisser trois
fois. Abonnez-vous à Mediapart. OK. et
abonnez-vous à Media Part, c'est c'est
le contrat, c'est être conforme à ma
caricature. Mais en l'occurrence, on euh
ce aujourd'hui, on voit bien qu'il faut
sortir de ça et qu'il faut défendre un
certain rapport au réel qui est ce
rapport à la à la vérité de fait sur le
présent, lequel est encombré de passé,
on le voit bien Zéemour qui est qui est
un falsificateur du passé, hein, qui
nous raconte un passé qui n'existe pas.
Alors pour revenir à à ce que vous
dites, c'est il y a un climat général
que racontait Paul, ça n'est pas arrivé
qu'à nous. Mais en France s'ajoute
quelque chose et sur la longueur et la
longue durée, je peux en témoigner.
C'est la corruption par aussi ce
journalisme de gouvernement qui en
France est en tête de gondole.
Alors, il faut expliquer ce que c'est le
journaliste, gouvernement. C'est le
journaliste qui se met sous le robinet
de l'information du gouvernement
et qui est qui est en lien, qui est
nommé, qui est promu, qui est caressé,
qui est et qui
qui s'est caressé
et qui regarde tout en haut et qui ne
regarde pas en bas, qui tout de suite va
juger avec plein de préjugés les gilets
jaunes et tenir un discours de mépris et
ainsi de suite. Et ce journaliste de
gouvernement, il est il est au cœur de
ça aujourd'hui. Zemour ne vient pas de
la marge du système. Zemour ne vient
même pas de l'extrême droite. Il a voté
Mitteran en 88. Il a voté Chevinement en
2002. Il est en tête de gondole du
Figaro encore aujourd'hui.
Il était au cœur du service public
l'émission du samedi soir. Donc c'est
vraiment ça l'enjeu pour moi, c'est que
c'est un champ de bataille. Alors
l'autocritique, c'est peut-être parfois
avoir pas été assez en dehors.
Aujourd'hui, je dirais que le mot
d'ordre, c'est être en dehors. Ce que
nous faisons, je dis juste ça pour qu'on
comprenne aussi pourquoi je suis ravi de
me retrouver avec Paul Morera. Ce qu'on
fait qui est dans les salles de cinéma
aujourd'hui première ligne qui est
fondée et dirigée par Paul avec Luuk
Herman et on coproduit avec Mediapart
Media Crash qui a tué le débat public.
Ce film, il est porté par la nouvelle
génération des plus jeunes que Paul et
moi, hein. C'est eux qui ont porté ça
parce qu'ils ont ce rapport au métier.
Et je voudrais terminer par ça. Moi,
quand je suis rentré dans le métier,
j'avais un côté journaliste militant
puisque j'étais engagé plutôt à
l'extrême gauche. Mais à l'époque, il y
avait un rapport commun au métier.
J'étais spécialisé dans les questions
d'éducation. J'étais dans une
association des journalistes éducation
que j'ai même présidé à un moment qui
s'appelait l'association presse
information jeunesse. Il y avait
là-dedans le Figaro, le service public,
l'humanité, le monde et la presse du
bouillonnement de la presse 68. Il y
avait des sensibilités différentes mais
on avait tous le même métier. Aucun
d'entre nous ne considérait que le
métier c'était le blab blabla des
opinions. C'était j'ai un petit style et
je te fais unito et je dis quoi il faut
en penser. Tous ces gens qui nous
critiquent et Dieu sait si
les donneurs de leçon. Non mais c'est
oui qui disent que nous soyons nous
serions les donneurs de leçon et on
pourrait citer plein de noms. Ce sont
des gens qui n'ont jamais sorti une info
de leur vie, qui n'ont jamais affronté
une difficulté à obtenir une info, à
faire un reportage au long cours, à
percer un secret d'état, à subir les
pressions. Ils n'ont jamais, ils n'ont
jamais, ils se sont contentés toujours
de dire leur point de vue. Et bien le
système politique et médiatique a promu
ça. Pourquoi ils proment ça ? pour
étouffer les vérités qui dérangent, pour
étouffer ce qui est le cœur de notre
métier. Et je mets en garde, Orwell
disait ça, George Orwell, il disait ça.
La liberté n'a de sens que si c'est la
liberté de dire aux gens ce qu'ils n'ont
pas envie d'entendre. Nous, notre
boulot, c'est de sortir des faits, des
problèmes, hein. On fait réfléchir un
étudiant en lui mettant un problème, pas
en lui mettant une solution, disant "Tu
te casses la tête et tu vas essayer de
trouver le problème." Ben, on met un
problème sur la table et la société
réfléchit à ce problème.
Et l'autocritique, elle est où là ? Ben
l'autocritique, elle est que nous on
fait partie de ça et on se bataille. Je
je vais pourquoi je donne pas je
pourrais donner une autocritique
personnelle de dire que moi ben
non sur votre profession le journalisme
de
Non mais moi attends je je suis désolé
je vais pas faire une autocritique de
cette profession que je combats. Moi
Medéia Part et toute mon histoire
personnelle elle est issue de ce combat.
Moi à un âge déraisonnable quand j'ai
créé Médiapart j'ai 55 ans. À un âge
déraisonnable j'ai rompu
quitté.
C'est un peu tard. C'est peut-être un
peu tard, mais Dieu sait que on peut
dire peu tard, mais on [rires] l'a fait,
on l'a fait. Hein ? Ce que je veux dire,
c'est pour ça que je dis un âge
déraisonnable, c'est-à-dire que
jamais d'âge des raisonnable.
Non, mais un Non, mais ce que je veux
dire, c'est cette idée que voilà, on
fait un chemin qui est un chemin de
lutte et de résistance. Pourquoi ? Parce
qu'on n'est pas au service de nous-même.
On n'est pas au service le journalisme,
c'est pas le privilège de ceux qui le
font. C'est au service d'un droit des
citoyens qui est un droit fondamental
qui est le droit de savoir. Et donc on
doit collectivement faire cette
bataille. C'est pour ça que je j'avais
une hésitation sur l'autocritique à part
de dire que moi j'ai dû rompre à un
moment et faire ce paris fou qui a été
la création de Médiia part avec François
Bonet et Laurent Mauit euh et de
rencontrer une nouvelle génération. Mais
au bout du compte, Méiapart,
Méia Part venu du monde de la presse
écrite, on est deux univers qui ont fait
ce choix. On ne donne leçon à personne,
on fait notre métier. Citez-moi une info
de première ligne ou de médiia part qui
a été foireuse. Citez-moi une info qui
n'est pas été d'intérêt public.
Citez-moi une info qui n'est pas obligée
à des prises de conscience auxquelles
les pouvoirs publics se refusaient.
Voilà, on sert à ça.
Le vieux il parle.
C'est un de ses grands talents. [rires]
Paul le journalisme de cours, le
journalisme de commande.
Ouais.
Celui qui reçoit un petit papier pour
faire chier l'autre. Je suis désolé, je
suis très vulgare.
Ouais. Mais moi alors moi je veux dire
un truc, je ne l'ai jamais rencontré
tout simplement parce que je suis dans
une autre sphère. Enfin moi franchement
j'ai je me rappelle la première fois que
j'ai une position un peu honorifique ou
de pouvoir ou je sais pas quoi, c'est
quand Alain Degreff Canal Plus me nomme
directeur adjoint de la rédaction.
J'arrivais même pas à m'en souvenir la
plupart du temps. En réalité, je
dirigeais un magazine d'investigation
qui s'appelait 90 minutes avec lequel
j'ai pris un plaisir énorme à raconter
l'info de manière libre pour un temps
avant de me faire virer mais par
Rodolphe Belmaire. Mais je peux te
raconter après pour une histoire qui a à
voir avec la Côte d'Ivoire. Euh je je je
me souviens que donc j'ai j'ai cette
petite position, c'est je suis surpris
parce que moi 2h20 je suis pigiste hein,
j'ai du mal à vendre mes papiers et donc
me voilà au volant d'un truc énorme dans
une multinationale et euh et je reçois
une invitation de l'Élysée euh pour les
vœux.
Ah bah
et alors je dis mais pourquoi je le
connais pas moi Chiracit Shirac à
l'époque. Pourquoi il m'invite ? Et j'ai
un truc mais vraiment à l'estomac où je
me dis mais faut pas y aller, faut pas y
aller. Même si au fond après je me
tourne et je me dis mais tout le monde y
va. Je dis bah non c'est pas nous. Enfin
tu es journaliste, tu vas pas au vœu du
président. Et je me je me rends compte
aujourd'hui que c'était une position
ultra marginale, presque bizarre en
fait. même à la limite, je me
questionne, je me dis "Ouais mais quand
même, tu étais trop radical tout ça."
Mais au fond, je suis convaincu d'un
truc, c'est que les journalistes
devraient maintenir une membrane
imperméable avec euh avec le pouvoir,
sauf avec les gens qui ont un dilemme,
parce que faut bien dire qu'ils nous
nourrissent. Il y a des gens qui sont au
pouvoir ou des des fonctionnaires, des
flics, des magistrats, enfin il y a des
gens qui des des gens qui étaient dans
des multinationales. Je moi je par
exemple, j'ai une relation amicale
longue avec un un insider qui venait de
l'industrie du tabac. Le mec à un moment
donné s'est dit "Putain, je suis en
train de vendre la mort à des gamins."
Et c'est il a mal vécu avec. Donc nous,
on vit sur les hommes qui ont des
dilemmes, qui viennent nous voir parce
qu'ils en peuvent enf ils se disent à un
moment donné, on a une morale et ça
colle plus quoi.
Vous êtes confesseur,
on est quelque part on leur sert. Ouais.
peut-être à les soulager ou à se dire
que ils auront fait un truc bien parce
que en fait tu es toujours et toi-même
en tant que journaliste, tu es toujours
dans des sortes de de rendez-vous avec
toi-même. Je parlais de la Côte
d'Ivoire, je peux la raconter cette
anecdote parce qu'elle m'a coûté une
place quand même. C'est en novembre
2004,
il y a en Côte d'Ivoire
deux avions ce coil qui pilotés par des
biolorusses qui lâchent des bombes sur
une base française. Il y a neuf soldats
américains euh français pardon qui sont
tués
et ça le le l'armée française enfin qui
est en gros monte sur Abidjan et
commence à sécuriser des points forts.
Ce qui fout la trouille aux partisans du
du président BGBO et un certain nombre
de enfin des évangélistes. Il y avait
beaucoup d'évangélistes dans dans ses
amis et ils entourent l'hôtel ivoire où
il y avait le dispositif de sécurité
français. Mais c'est des gens c'est des
manifestants. Ils sont en t-shirt, ils
chantent des cantiques et tout. Il reste
là pendant 2 jours et au deuxème jour
l'armée française ouvre le feu parce
qu'on a touché au chars et cetera. Mais
enfin c'est c'est c'est touché où
au char il y avait des des tanks autour
de de l'hôtel d'Ivoire. Donc les au bout
de 2 jours, il y en a qui sont approchés
des chars mais bon ils commettent ce
qu'on appelle un crime de guerre. Enfin
quand tu tires à balle réelle sur des
manifestants des armées, ça s'appelle un
crime de guerre. Et je vois que le truc
est étouffé. Or, nous on a une équipe
sur place coup de bol un peu parce qu'on
a vu que enfin il se passait des choses
intéressantes. Donc j'ai envoyé Stéphane
Aman euh couvrir cette histoire et on
filme le moment où à l'hélicoptère de
combat l'armée française tire sur une
manifestation de civil sur les ponts de
la lagune. Et c'est là c'est une caméra
indépendante enf je veux dire. Et je et
et je regarde ma télévision tous les
soirs et je vois rien mais rien du tout.
Et je me dis mais comment c'est possible
? Je veux dire les images de l'hôtel
ivoire, c'est elles sont pas de moi,
c'est les Ivoiriens qui les ont filmé.
Elles se baladent. à l'époque, c'était
pas internet mais on nous les envoyé par
mail enfin et donc tout le monde les a
ces images et elles ne sont pas
diffusées. Et on parle de il y a eu des
œufs chauffés à l'hôtel ivoiri en fait
c'est pas ça. Il y a pas eu des
échauffés, il y a eu un crime de guerre
à l'hôtel ivoir. Et donc nous on se dit
bah voilà on on va le diffuser le sujet
et on le diffuse mais on doit se battre
incroyablement parce que les pressions
viennent de l'Élysée. On doit envoyer le
DVD au ministère de de la défense. Mais
ça c'est la direction de Canal Plus qui
prend cette cette décision. Elle envoie
le DVD pour le montrer et il y a le soir
même une fois qu'ils avaient des infos
Michel Mar qui était le ministre de la
défense à l'époque qui explique dans le
cadre du elle invente un concept c'est
la légitime défense élargie c'est que
comme c'est pas sur la légitime défense
il faut reconnaître qu'il y a quand même
eu 350 munitions explosives qui ont été
tirées sur des civils qui étaient sur le
pont de la lagune. Faut inventer un
concept. Donc c'est la légitime défense
élargie que dans ce cadre-là, alors
qu'ils avaient menti pendant un mois en
disant "Non, non, on n jamais tiré. Euh
non non, non, il s'est rien passé. Euh
et donc nous, on diffuse notre film
dans toute cette difficulté là de
pression, il y aura pas de rediffusion
et cetera, mais à partir de ce
moment-là, on est mis sous tutelle. À
partir de ce moment-là, le la direction
dit euh avant c'est moi qui décidait des
des sujets, comment il partait et
cetera. Et à partir de ce moment-là, on
crée un bidule qui s'appelle le comité
d'investigation où il y a tout un tas de
gens à Costard à qui tu faut que tu
vendes tes idées, ce qui n'existait pas
avant. Et puis bon, petit à petit, le
nœud se resserre autour de mon cou et
jusqu'à ce que une douzaine de mois plus
tard, euh on me dise que bon, finalement
ça fait double emploi avec et on met fin
à l'émission. On met pas fin à ma
participation à Canal Plus, mais on me
vire. On dit non, tu es un mec très bien
mais tu vas travailler de l'extérieur.
Euh évidemment, tu perds le tu perds le
pouvoir. En fait, c'est ça qui se passe.
Tu perds ton indépendance. Ça ne peut
pas envoyer un journaliste à l'étranger
ou ailleurs. D'ailleurs,
etoui, le fait que il y a des sujets qui
soient occultés par les grands journaux
télévisés comme France Télévision, nos
impôts, TF1, France 3, nos impôts
et les autres, ça arrive souvent, ça
arrive pas souvent. Est-ce que c'est ça
qui participe à la défiance ?
Mais nous c'est ce qu'on vit tous les
jours. Méapart, les scoupes à Méapart,
abonnez-vous,
ça tombe non mais ça tombe comme à
gravelotte
les infos voilà et puis certaines où on
se dit mais ça devrait faire comme on
dit dans le monde anglo-saxon les
headlines. C'estd c'est une évidence, ça
doit être pris quand même. Prenons le
dernier rebondissement de ce feuilleton
immense qui est l'affaire Sarkozy
Kaddafi qu'on a lancé. euh à partir de
2011 avant la justiceé monsieur PLEL Oui
oui. Avant la justice donc qui est quand
même une histoire énorme la corruption
d'une d'une démocratie par une dictature
par l'argent d'une dictature avec tout
un clan. Il y a presque une 25
trentaines de personnes concernées par
la mise en cause judiciaire.
C'est c'est un un feuilleton encore une
fois énorme.
Vous avez des preuves monsieur P. Oui
oui bon continuons comme ça mais mais et
du coup on a comment dire le dernier le
dernier épisode qu'on a largement
documenté Fabri Harfi notamment sur
Médiap c'est un épisode de manipulation
médiatique.
C'est c'est exactement ça. C'estàd que
Sarkozy chaque fois qu'il y avait une
nouvelle étape judiciaire de ce
feuilleton, il a toujours essayé. Il a
dit que notre document était faux. Il a
perdu, il a dit ceci, il a dit cela. Et
chaque fois, il faut une nouvelle
parade. Et la parade, c'était il y a un
peu plus d'un an a été avec la
complicité de Paris Match et de BFM de
mettre en scène un faux revirement de
quelques secondes de l'intermédiaire
Takédine qui est aux abois au Liban où
il fuit la justice déjà hein où il est
normalement en fuite par rapport aux
condamnations de la justice. Et ils ont
mis ça en scène avec qui ? avec une
personne dont moi j'ai découvert à cette
occasion l'ampleur et qui au fond sert
toutes sortes de présidents qui est
Michel Marchand dit Mimi Marchand
appelle la papesse de la la press people
mais qui avant a fait dans les boîtes de
nuit a fait tout dans ce monde interlope
on a le droit mais dans un monde qui est
entre les indicateurs de police et et
les grands bandits hein c'est
où il y a des dossiers
qui a fait de la prison qui a fait et
cetera qui a on a le droit de se
reconvertir et je suis pour la
réinsertion on a
je suis pour la réinsertion des
délinquants. pas de problème.
[grognement] Mais du coup cette personne
se retrouve qui est au cœur de la
présidence de la République l'actuelle
de Macron. Elle contrôle, c'est elle qui
a choisi la photographe officielle de la
présidence actuelle. C'est elle qui est
au cœur au départ du couple Macron. À
tel point qu'il y a une fameuse photo où
elle est là derrière le bureau
présidentiel et et elle cette photo est
là et en même temps elle est donc au
cœur de Sarkozi. Elle était au cœur de
l'organisation des obsèques de tapis. Le
boulot de cette dame, c'est de faire sur
papier glacé les bonnes infos,
c'est-à-dire ce qui arrange ses clients
et que les infos que un paparadzi, mais
un véritable paparadzi indépendant va
prendre pas sur commande, ça ne sorte
pas. que un enquêteur de la téléfilm que
ça ça ne sorte pas et ainsi de suite. Et
là et bien cette personne elle va se
retrouver au cœur d'une opération mais
qui est une opération alors de pied ni
clé un peu barbousard avec quand même
beaucoup d'argent avec euh des millions
pour d'une part obtenir ce revirement
euh totalement euh totalement euh
foireux de Takedin sur lequel
[raclement de gorge] il est depuis
revenu. blanchir
blanchir Sarkozi Sarkozi 2 jours après
et chez Rutel Crif en disant voilà cette
indignité vous rendez compte tout ce que
j'ai subi et tout ça bon et aujourd'hui
on sait tous les grâce à l'enquête
judiciaire tous les coups de fils les
textaux les SMS enfin je veux dire le le
avec avec Sarkozy qui est au cœur au
cœur au cœur de l'opération et puis on
découvre que il fallait aussi corrompre
un magistrat libanais pour faire sortir
de prison un desfil Kaddafi qui est là
pour une autre sombrooire d'argent
Hannibal Kaddafi pour que il viennent
dire que ce que nous avons dit est faux
c'est-à-dire tout ça c'est et vous vous
retrouvez avec un truc où le patron de
BFM Marc Olivier Faugiel dit à son
rédacteur en chef qui témoigne dans Méia
Crash il a quitté BFM depuis et il
reçoit l'ordre de la direction on a une
exclusivité avec Paris Match faut
diffuser et lui il sent bien que c'est
foireux parce que c'est un enquêteur
c'est soit tout de suite il voit c'est
un homme de télé il voit que le même des
détails comment s'est pris comment le
micro enfin on est habitué il
[raclement de gorge] une attitude
physique tout enfin tu vois que c'est
bidon
et ça ne tenait pas une seconde. Du coup
faut voir ce que ça signifie pour nous
moi j'ai dû passer après dans des
chaînes d'infos parce que autant on
reprend pas nos bonnes infos autant là
on vient dire vous vous êtes planté
venez rendre des comptes venez comp il a
fait n'importe quoi. Et du coup et du
coup je dois passer pour aller faire ça
comme au moment de Cusac. Vous vous
souvenez les 4 mois l'épreuve l'épreuve
il faill y aller moment de Causac.
Rappelez-vous la une du JDD,
la protection des sources, jamais
la une du JDD pour dire qu'ausac blanchi
avec cette mauvaise question posée par
la direction des impôts et par les les
collaborateurs de Kizzac à
l'administration
suisse pour obtenir la mauvaise réponse.
Donc fallait fallait tenir bon quand on
a un truc comme ça. Et donc voilà, on
est quand même dans un moment que tout
ça n'est pas indifférent quand je parle
de Mimi Marchand qui est au cœur de ce
système qui est la pipalisation,
c'està-dire on vous va vous faire du
divertissement, on va vous faire du
people, on va vous faire de la
personnalisation pour ne pas faire
d'infos. Mais il y a par exemple,
prenons Boloré qui est au cœur de C News
et de la promotion de Zemour. Qu'est-ce
qu'il a aussi avec son groupe ? Il a
Avas. Avas, c'est le premier euh
fournisseur de de d'emplacement
publicitaires. C'est énorme. C'est un
groupe mondial,
un réseau extraordinaire.
C'est un réseau extraordinaire. À la
fois la pub, donc le moyen de pression.
Tu me fais un mauvais papier, je te
retire la pub. Et il y a toujours, je
répète un exemple dans Media Crash,
allez voir et vous découvrirez que c'est
là comment tout d'un coup la pub s'en va
et ça coûte 16 millions au journal L
Monde qui du coup est obligé
d'allermander des pubs.
[raclement de gorge] 16 millions d'euros
pour un papier. Bon toute l'histoire est
racontée mais c'est pas seulement ça.
Avas c'est tous les communiquants.
Tentacule de
c'est tout ce qu'on retrouve dès qu'il
faut habiller une histoire, dès qu'il
faut arranger une histoire
quand il faut commander à un journaliste
un bon papier sur une société. Oui, mais
en fait c'est plus c'est pas c'est pas
une commande, c'est pas je te dis ou je
te file et cetera. C'est justement
beaucoup plus incestueux et c'est et
c'est beaucoup plus
incestueux dans un mélange des gens,
dans une forme de de de relation. ce que
ce que disait Paul tout à l'heure,
c'estàd il faut se tenir,
il faut tenir la distance et ce qui et
et en fait un journaliste, il doit
connaître plein de gens, c'est normal,
mais j'allais dire il doit en fréquenter
aucun. C'est-à-dire que il peut y avoir
une exception, il peut arriver dans nos
longues carrières à un moment, il y a
une histoire personnelle qui se joue
mais on sait que c'est l'exception.
Si Edou Planel était tombé amoureux de
Jérôme Kausac, qu'est-ce qui se serait
passé ?
Je suis pas tombé amoureux de Jérôme
Kusac. Je ne vois pas bien quel est le
scénario. Qu'est-ce qui serait passé ?
Est-ce que vous voulez dire est-ce que
parfois il faut pas déranger ses propres
amis, ses propres relations ? Bien sûr,
ça il faut le faire tout le temps.
Mais bien sûr. Mais moi, quel est quelle
est modestement ma propre histoire ?
Moi, je suis un jeune.
J'ai quand Méran arrive au pouvoir, j'ai
en 1981, je suis de ceux qui souhaitaent
qu'on en sorte de cette droite
interminable qui étouffait. Ça change le
changement, l'alternance 80. Bon, OK, je
souhaite ça, j'ai 29 ans, mais je me dis
une fois que ça change, bah on fait
comme faisait le canard enchaîné sous la
droite quand il y avait des affaires de
diamant de Giscar, quand il y avait et
cetera, on sort les choses.
Diamant de Bassa,
c'est c'est la ligne la ligne ne change
pas. C'est-à-dire qu'on va pas parce que
c'est un pouvoir amis étouffer des
affaires. Comment commence mauvaise
réputation ? Au début, on disait que
j'étais au casb
comment
Greenpeace.
Oui. Non mais la cellule de l'Élysée,
Greenpeace, le cabinet noir, toutes les
affaires de la présidence mitéran. Et du
coup comme toujours et ça s'est répandu
aujourd'hui au maximum avec les réseaux
sociaux, on invente des légendes comme
font les services de renseignement. On
t'invente que tu étais au KGB, après on
t'invente que tu étais à la CIA, on
t'invente que tu es is gauchiste, on
t'invente que tu es un fraudeur fiscal,
on t'invente et et ainsi de suite. Mais
pour on veut noyer son chien, on dit
qu'il a la rage. Mais là, j'ai j'ai de
toute façon, on sait que vous êtes de la
DGS.
Ah bon ? Ah finalement, je suis je suis
agent triple. Alors DGSE, DGSE, KGB,
Mossad, quadruple alors Mossade et et
CIA. Mais au bout du compte ce que ce
que
KGB cit à votre époque
bon FSB maintenant
gru ça c'est service de renseignement
militaire mais ce que ce que je veux
dire c'est que euh notre métier et c'est
pour ça je voudrais insister parce que
on est on parle forcément à la première
personne mais ce qui nous sauve
c'est d'avoir une conception de ce
métier comme un métier collectif
c'est un sacerdoce c'est quoi
ou écoute écoute bien ce que je veux
dire on a vu aussi dans notre paysage
des gens s'égarés
en devenant les héros de leurs propres
enquêtes et en vivant ça comme leur
propre aventure personnelle, parfois
avec les meilleures intentions du monde.
Mais je redis le meilleur contrôleur
d'un journaliste, c'est son collègue qui
va le relire, qui va discuter avec toi,
qui va faire ça, qui va et ça c'est pour
moi c'est essentiel. Et donc le
sacerdoce il est collectif. Ça veut dire
qu'on boit des coups hein. Ça veut dire
qu'on n'est pas des moines. Ça veut dire
qu'on sait faire la fête. [rires] Ça
veut dire qu'on a de l'humour. Mais on
le fait dans notre univers.
Je vous coupe le sacerdoce à l'heure
actuelle. Alors vous allez me dire qu'il
y a une jeune classe de journalistes qui
sort toute fraîche que tout va bien que
Mais pourquoi on vous reçoit vous ?
Parce que vous êtes des journalistes
qui comment expliquer ça ? porter
correctement le le le mot le nom
journaliste.
On a regardé votre boulot. Rigole pas
toi là-bas. On a regardé votre boulot.
Il se moque de nous en fait. Vous
séparez. Mais non, il est gêné parce
qu'il doit faire un compliment. Il est
pas habitué. Il faut qu'il habit son
truc. [rires]
OK, vous êtes bons les vieux, ça va.
Mais autre, on lit la presse
pratiquement toute la journée
pratiquement une grande partie de la
presse internationale de et française
mais la plupart du temps c'est merdeux
mielleux, c'est pas bon. C'est c'est du
colportage du délayage de news AFP.
C'est c'est simplement de c'est recopié.
C'est pratiquement du téléphone arabe.
Ça dépend en fait. Le truc c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on on est dans un un
moment très particulier où il y a
tellement de choses sur les réseaux
sociaux. Moi je vois par exemple, je
m'intéresse plutôt à ce qui se passe au
Moyen-Orient. Donc je suis quelques
personnes euh et parfois je suis au
courant des combats qu'il y a euh je
sais pas à Raka euh au moment où ils ont
lieu quoi parce que le type il est là et
il envoie un tweet au moment où ça se
passe. Donc bon, c'est ça c'est un degré
assez pointu, mais énormément de gens
ont une relation à une source directe de
l'information aujourd'hui qui fait que
cette les médias dit mainstream doivent
se poser sérieusement la question de
comment ils traitent l'information parce
qu'ils arrivent toujours en deuxème
rempart rambard, tu vois, c'est qu' ils
arrivent dans un terrain où la plupart
des gens qui s'intéressent à l'info
savent déjà ce qui s'est passé les
dernières 24 heures. Donc ils doivent se
poser la question des langues des
longues et cetera. Je parle pas de Média
part parce que Média part vous avez une
immédiaté. Une fois que vous savez un
truc, vous pouvez le publier et vous
faites l'événement et au fond vous vous
nourrissez plutôt la la première ligne
de de l'info. Mais je pense à tout ce
qui est la presse euh normale mainstream
que tu décris, cet effet de vu, euh
délayé et cetera, je crois qu'il est
beaucoup lié à la révolution numérique
et et à la difficulté de la de la presse
mainstream pour trouver sa place. Il y
en a qui arrivent hein, je veux dire par
moment tu as des éclats. Tu dis "A ouais
cette histoire elle est vraiment bien
pensée. C'est un angle original par
rapport à ce que tu peux lire dans le
dans le dans enfin dans le le Z guist
quoi, de de des réseaux sociaux. Mais
c'est un énorme un énorme défi. Je
voulais juste revenir sur un truc que
disait Dou qui était très juste et je
pense qu'il faut vraiment que le grand
public le comprenne, c'est que on a
faire face, on est en fait on est dans
une guerre de la perception. C'estd que
des gens comme Mimi Marchand, comme Anne
Méo, comme enfin c'est des c'est des
grands professionnels
à divers niveaux. Pas
alors par exemple Méo, c'est une dame
qui conseille les grands patrons
français sur leur image
et les politiques aussi.
Vous dire elle a bien le droit ?
Non mais absolument mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est un boulot c'est un
boulot qui est
c'est ça c'est des gens qui vont et de
manière extrêmement subtile. C'est pas
des imbéciles. C'est des gens qui savent
sur quel bouton appuyer et cetera, mais
en gros ils te proposent une narration,
une histoire toute faite clé en main,
intelligente,
engaging comme on dit en anglais, qui
qui intéresse le lecteur et cetera. Par
exemple, dans l'affaire Carlos Gon, ça
va être de mettre en valeur la relation
amoureuse entre lui et sa femme, comment
elle s'est sacrifié pour lui et cetera.
C'est une facette de l'histoire qui est
une fac pour ça on les appelle les spin
doctor. Tu vois parce qu'il ils tournent
l'histoire de manière à te présenter la
façade la plus avantageuse pour eux ou
pour leurs clients. Donc donc c'est pas
c'est pas brutal. Il y a jamais de
disons, tu vas me faire un article sur
tel et tel truc. Je crois pas que ça
existe ça. Peut-être ça existe ici ou
là. Bon, mais c'est vraiment à la marge
quoi. Mais en fait, tu es face à des
gens extrêmement intelligents qui te
connaissent extrêmement bien, qui
connaissent tes réflexes, qui
connaissent tes besoins et qui vont
savoir te met te faire une tambouille
qui va t'attirer et si tu ne fais pas si
tu n'appliques pas, moi ma citation
préférée de de d'Albert Londres, on a
tous des citations d'Albert Londres,
c'est la seule ligne éditoriale, c'est
la ligne de chemin de fer. Et à un
moment donné où il faut il faut y aller
quoi. Il faut
c'est bien qu'on qu'on il faut avoir des
relations avec tu peux pas faire
autrement que d'avoir des relations avec
ces gens-là mais il y a un moment donné
ton ticket de métro et tu vas ta mot
et et tu te fais ton opinion toi-même et
tu et tu rencontres tes contacts. Et ça
il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui dans la
presse telle qu'elle existe, le modèle
économique dans lequel vivent un certain
nombre de journalistes, je pense aux
chaînes tout info, il y a pas le temps
de le faire. Il y a pas le temps de le
faire. Donc tu appliques la narration
qu'on t'offre de la manière la plus
avantageuse possible. C'est c'est le
l'exemple que décrivait Edv euh tout à
l'heure et qui est tout à fait euh exact
par rapport par rapport à à la question
sur euh le côté euh suiviste et cetera
qui est accéléré évidemment par
l'information en temps réel hein, les
dépêches AFP ce que tout le monde sait.
Je pense qu'on est dans un comment dire,
on est au on est tout début d'une
révolution dont dont on n'imagine pas à
la suite. Moi je pense aujourd'hui que
le numérique c'est pas seulement une
révolution industrielle comme la machine
à vapeur, comme l'électricité où à
chaque fois ça a été une révolution de
la communication, le rapport au temps et
à l'espace c'est modifié et cetera. Je
pense que c'est de la même ampleur dans
ces conséquences que l'invention de
l'imprimerie au mi-temps du 15e siècle.
et et ça modifie le rapport à la
connaissance, au savoir. Et c'est une
bataille, c'est pas c'est forcément
bien. C'est une la l'histoire de
l'imprimerie, c'est quoi ? Tout d'un
coup les clairs, ceux qui étaient les
possesseurs du savoir, ceux qui savaient
lire, ceux qui étaient les copistes et
cetera. Tout d'un coup, ils se disent
"Merde,
merde, merde ! Ils vont savoir lire,
merde, ils vont connaître les secrets,
merde, ils vont réfléchir tout seul."
Pas un film qui parle de ça ? Non, qui
est complètement différent ? le livre d'
lit ou un truc comme ça.
Ah, peut-être. Alors, je connais pas.
Mais dans tous les cas de figure, ce que
je veux dire, c'est qu'à ce moment-là se
passe une bataille. Nous, on cite
souvent dans les livres d'histoire le
côté formidable de cette bataille qui
est celui qu'on a hérité, qui est la
Renaissance. On appelle ça la
Renaissance. C'est les Lumières, c'est
Léonard de Vincy, c'est Montagne, le
premier homme qui écrit à la première
personne. C'est la question de l'autre,
c'est et cetera tout ça. Mais en même
temps qu'il y a tout ça, il y a tout le
côté terrible, la face noire. En même
temps que Montigne écrit, il y a les
guerres de religion et on se trucide
entre catholiques et protestants
ici même ici même à Paris avec une
violence. Il y a euh l'Espagne qui dans
la conquête détruit détruit euh des
peuples, détruit fait des génocides de
fait euh euh détruit des civilisations
et invente du coup la pureté de sang,
l'inquisition et du coup l'empi des
sangrés et du coup on expulse les Juifs
d'Espagne, on expulse les morts
d'Espagne, tout ça. Il y a cette bâtard
bataille ombre et lumière hein. Et ça ça
va durer quelques temps jusqu'à
justement ce qu'on en on soit le produit
de ça, c'est-à-dire les lumières,
l'invention des idées démocratiques,
l'article 1er de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme. Nous naissons libre
ég en droit, tout ça. Nous sommes dans
un moment semblable mais à une toute
petite échelle pour l'humanité quoi.
C'est ce notre univers là dans lequel on
est, il n'a même pas il a 25 ans même
pas. C'est un quart de siècle, c'est
rien. Donc on est dans ce moment de
bataille et tout ce que nous discutons
là, c'est justement cet affrontement.
Pour moi, c'est ma lecture de ce que
nous vivons, y compris à l'échelle
internationale. Il y a un vieux monde
qui est condamné. Il sait qu'il est
condamné. C'est un monde où ne compte
que le fait de s'enrichir, d'avoir le
monde de la prédation, le monde de la
domination, le monde de la rapidité, le
monde de l'immédiateté, le monde de de
au fond de de l'irresponsabilité, hein.
Et
je vous coupe, je vous coupe dans cet
envolé.
Il y a certaines personnes qui qui vous
chargent d'ailleurs sur les réseaux
etoui, il sort ses infos pour faire
chier quand il est en vie. C'estàd que
là
vo là on change de sujet mais mon vieux
monde je le récupérerai tout à l'heure.
Alors c'est excuse-moi j'ai pas compris
ce que tu as dit à cause du masque. Bah
je Etoui il sort ses infos pour énerver
quand il a envie d'énerver.
Dernier exemple en date. Ouais dernier
exemple en date.
Bon mon vieux monde on on laissera
tomber. Alors je
mais ça on sait qu'il est en train de
crever.
Il est en train de crever. Il y a un
nouveau monde qui a naître et entre les
deux
surgissent les monstres. C'est ça.
Antonio Gramchi.
La phrase d'introduction de Marcel de
son dernier livre. La France sous-prise.
Alors quand m que c'est pas PL qui
appuie sur un bouton. D'accord. La
moustache c'est c'est réincarnation.
Quand j'entends les communistes sur
internet dire "Oh PL, il sort une info
sur Rousell juste en pleine campagne,
c'est parce queil commence à monter dans
les sondages.
L'info sur Rousell de son emploi ou pas
fictif, vous l'aviez depuis quand ? Hm,
nous on est on est comme un cuisinier
hein. Euh, on sert quand c'est prêt. On
n'attend pas. Meilleur exemple, le
meilleur exemple c'est entre les deux
tours en 2012. Le document libien, on
l'obtient, on prend le temps de le
vérifier. Et là, on est entre les deux
tours et Sarkozy est candidat face à
Hollande.
Et la gestion politicienne que tout le
monde pourrait nous reprocher, c'est de
ne pas sortir le document. C'est dire
d'épouser un calendrier électoral. Nous,
notre calendrier, il est pas électoral.
C'est le droit de savoir. C'est le droit
de savoir du public. Donc on sort quand
c'est bon. C'est-à-dire quand c'est
vérifié, recoupé. Dans le cadre
Roussell, on a sorti quand c'était
vérifié, recoupé et ce n'est pas
terminé. Nouvelles informations et
révélations à venir dans les jours
prochains. Qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire Rousselle ? C'est une histoire
toute simple. Je suis de la génération
qui est par ses révélations sur les
illégalités de financement commises
aussi bien à droite qu'à gauche a permis
les lois sur le financement de la vie
politique. Aujourd'hui, les partis
politiques qui ont de moins en moins
d'adhérents, donc pas de cotisation,
vivent de nos impôts
et du crédit des banques.
Crédit des banques pour les campagnes
électorales, mais c'est remboursé, ils
vivent de nos impôts. C'està-dire qu'en
fonction de leur résultat, ils ont y
compris en tant que parti, ils ont une
dotation chaque année. Cette dotation
leur permet de payer des permanents. OK.
Un collaborateur de l'Assemblée
nationale, il est collaborateur d'un élu
de la nation. C'est le nom de député. Un
député, il n'est pas élu de son
territoire, il est élu de sa nation. La
nation toute entière, il est fait pour
fabriquer les lois et pour contrôler
l'exécutif. Donc un assistant
parlementaire, son métier payé sur les
fonds publics, non pas du parti mais de
l'Assemblée nationale, il est de
travailler pour l'Assemblée nationale
via son député pour l'élaboration des
lois. Donc en clair, quel est le sens de
nos révélations que nous confirmons, que
nous maintenons, c'est que Fabien
vous avez sorti parce que c'était chaud.
Fabien Rousell Fabien Rousell était en
fait un permanent politique du parti
communiste travaillant pour sa
fédération qu'il tenait très fermement
et c'est comme ça qu'il a battu Pierre
Laurent et qu'il a pu prendre la
direction du parti communiste et il
était un permanent et le député le parti
lui avait demandé de payer en tant
qu'assistant parlementaire quelqu'un qui
était au service du parti. D'autres
partis ont fait ça. Il n'y a aucun
acharnement particulier de notre part
vis-à-vis du parti communiste. C'est
l'affaire du modèem, c'est une affaire
d'assistant parlementaire, c'est
l'affaire du Front National devenu le
Rassemblement national et c'est en
partie l'affaire qui concerne la France
insoumise. Toute affaire sur lesquelles
Médiia Part a multiplié les révélations.
Et donc c'est encore une fois une
question légitime. Par ailleurs, nous
sommes en campagne présidentielle
des gens qu'on courir
l'élection mais obtenir des scores. Les
scores vont leur permettre d'avoir des
députés, de rester à la tête de leur
formation, de représenter l'intérêt
général. Le travail de journalistes
indépendants pendant une campagne
présidentielle au service du droit de
savoir du public, c'est de retapisser
l'ensemble des candidats. Les électeurs
aujourd'hui, il y a de nouvelles
révélations de libération sur la
primaire LR. Et bien le fait qu'il y
avait des électeurs euh raattus de
manière communautaire y compris des
étrangers alors qu'elle est contre le
vote des droits des étrangers à la
primaire dont PCR est sortie gagnante,
c'était Médiapart. [grognement]
Nous avons fait des enquêtes sur le
financement de la campagne de Macron en
temps et en heure. Nous faisons ce
travail et d'ailleurs la boîte noire
comme on dit chez nous de l'article sur
Fabien Rousell rappelle toutes les
enquêtes sur tous les candidats. Donc je
suis très triste de voir des gens qui
sont normalement intelligents, qui sont
qui des communistes.
Oui. Non mais je vois compris des noms
de personnes que je connais dont je suis
et c qui ont ce réflexe partisan.
C'est-à-dire que disent bon au lieu de
se dire bah c'est à la loyale médiapard
fait son travail et et l'info l'info est
bonne. Alors
pareil pour la la Masératite du Pont
Moritti.
Ben la Masératite du Pont Moritti c'est
pas n'importe quoi, je suis désolé. La
Masératide du Pont Moritti c'est un
avocat qui reçoit 100 100000 € d'une
société des séchelles un paradis fiscal
qui de d'une société des séchelles pour
quelqu'un qui n'est pas son client.
C'estàd c'est pas son client mais il
reçoit 100000 € et avec ces 100000 € il
va à Monaco. Pourquoi ? Parce que
justement on va pas l'embêter sur la
provenance de cet argent et il y ajoute
un petit peu de liquide parce qu'il ne
prend pas l'ensemble des 100000 € et il
s'achète une Maérati y compris avec du
liquide. Bon bref, c'est une histoire
aberrante y compris en terme
qui date qui date d'
en terme en terme de déontologie des
avocats. Mais encore une fois, les
histoires on les a pas en réserve comme
ça. Vous savez, on va sortir le dossier
machin, on va sortir et cetera. Les
histoires arrivent en plus c'est comme
toujours quand on commence une histoire
et bien ça en réveille d'autres des
gens. Nous on est là pour donner du
courage aux gens. ouvrage à la
profession qui du coup hein quand même
par rapport à votre tableau de tout à
l'heure je trouve que la profession se
bat et y compris cette nouvelle presse
qu'on s'est réduit comme une peau de
chagrin. Oui, mais elle elle se bat
quand même. Je veux dire quand s'est
créé, il y avait pas envoyé spécial, il
y avait pas investigation. 9,
il y avait il y avait envoyé spécial en
2008 déjà. C'est alors c'est c'est cash
investigation qui est venu
Cach c'est en 2011
voilà qui est venu en refor. Donc je
veux dire et puis ça et puis il y avait
pas par exemple ces consortiums
d'enquête qu'on fait tous hein autour
d'élix autour et cetera. Mais ce que ce
que je veux dire c'est que on n'est pas
il y a il y a il y a pas d'autres agenda
et c'est l'image de la ligne de chemin
de fer qui était l'image du reporteur.
Il y a pas d'autres agenda et donc c'est
triste de voir et je voudrais juste dire
un truc important pour moi
tout tout notre temps, c'est vous qui
non un truc un truc
en fait c'est un manque de culture
démocratique que la réaction française
monte dans un pays à culture
démocratique y compris des gens du parti
communiste demanderaient des comptes à
Fabien Roussell. Voilà, c'estàd qu'il ne
serait pas dans une réaction pavlovienne
de faire bloc. Il ne serait pas dans
l'idée ah bah ils ont cette fois-ci ils
servent les intérêts. Ceux qui savent
les critiques de la France insoumise sur
Mediaapart savent que Mediaapart est pas
en train de servir les intérêts de tel
ou tel parti et que ce n'est pas et que
et et d'ailleurs quand on avait fait des
révélations sur la perquisition sur la
France insoumise, Dieu sait si la France
insoumise nous en avait voulu. Donc je
trouve ça très triste parce que on voit
que nous sommes une démocratie de basse
intensité. La seule question c'est
est-ce que notre info est bonne ou non ?
Je maintiens que Fabien Roussell ne
travaillait pas comme assistant
parlementaire mais comme permanent
politique du parti communiste et que
l'ensemble des cadres dirigeants du
parti communiste le savait.
Alors je je fais beaucoup parler Edoui
parce que Eddou doit nous quitter un peu
plus un peu plus tôt. Paul on va rester
avec un peu plus tard.
Paul, vous tu veux euh rebondir,
rajouter quelque chose avant qu'on parle
de médiia crash ?
Euh écoute, je je je j'entends la
critique qui est faite où oui, c'est
peut-être un truc d'opportunité et
j'entends aussi ce que dit Edi.
Effectivement, tout le monde en a pris
pour son grade à Média part, vous avez
été assez cuménique en la matière. Tu
entends aussi autre chose, c'est que en
campagne électorale, il est normal de
retapisser comme on dit en police
judiciaire et de voir le rapport à
l'argent, le rapport à la vérité, le
rapport à la transparence. Monsieur
Roussell, il est pas le dernier hein à
dire des choses sur la morale publique
et cetera. Et parfois, on s'en veut
après l'élection disant "Mais merde,
pourquoi on l'a pas fait avant ?
Et on le découvre après on est en droit
de nous le reprocher en disant "Les
gars, vous avez pas fait votre boulot et
vous nous avez permis de voter pour
celui-là." D'une certaine manière, on
pourrait dire qu'il y a des choses qu'on
a peut-être pas trouvé sur Macron avant
son élection.
Oui. Non, mais c'est c'est enfin le le
boulot d'un journaliste, c'est quand
même ça à un moment donné quoi. C'est de
révéler ce qui reste dans l'ombre et qui
pose des problèmes sur le plan de Ouais.
du bien public en fait.
En respectant la charte de Munique.
C'est quoi la charte de Munique ?
71.
Ah, il sauve. Ben non, ben la charte de
Munich, c'est le truc que personne ne
respecte sur la pluralité, le respect de
l'indépendance des journalistes. Dans
les elle est dans la charte
déontologique de Médiap. C'est le
document le plus abouti des syndicats
européens. C'est pour ça qu' était mis à
jour très récemment.
Voilà. Si et est le document
déontologique le plus abouti. Et il est
dit une phrase, il est dit qu'un
journaliste digne de ce nom n'est pas au
service de son actionnaire ni de la
puissance publique mais du public. C'est
justement la phrase que j'ai sortie moi
à la direction de Canal et tout ça m'a
quand même mis dehors. C'est pour ça que
je dis c'est c'est oui mais pour des
lois pour des dispositions de de
protection qu' soit dans la loi.
On va parler sûrement de la
concentration des médias à un moment
donné. Moi, je me souviens parfaitement
du moment où Vivendy achète 100 % de
canal début 2000. Et je me je me
souviens d'une grande messe parce qu'on
était quand même inquiet quoi. Enfin euh
c'était Jean Jean-René Fourtou à
l'époque.
Non, c'était pas Fourtou, c'était
Messier.
C'était Messier,
c'était Jean-Marie Messier. Donc moi je
me souviens d'une grande messe avec
Jean-Marie Messier un truc pas public he
juste avec
juste juste nous enfin les salariés
canal de l'éditorial et Jean-Marie
Messier et l'escur où Messier nous jure
la main sur le cœur queon ne touchera
pas l'indépendance éditoriale la liberté
éditoriale de Canal Plus c'est ce qu'il
aime le plus c'est un enfant de canal il
défendra cette ce devoir d'irrévérence
et cetera et cetera donc bon nous on
écoute ça d'une oreille il s'engage à
publier une charte. Donc tu vois, tu as
Munique, tu as la charte qui est
vraiment la charte de l'entreprise qui
garantit l'indépendance totale vis-à-vis
de l'actionnaire, l'indépendance
éditoriale et bon en gros, 3 ans après,
on est euh enfin nous, on est viré, tu
vois. C'est c'est il y a si tu veux il y
a en fait c'est c'est un texte qui
peut-être que j'ai je suis j'ai été
rendu un peu amè par le fait que jamais
j'ai pu disons forcer un signataire de
ce genre de traité ou de de charte
c'était une charte éditoriale à ce qu'il
la respecte parce qu' en vérité après tu
te tu te cognes la la la réalité de
l'actionnaire la réalité de l'intérêt de
l'entreprise et en ce qui me concerne en
tout cas euh ça n'a pas tenu En fait, ma
liberté éditoriale n'a pas tenu face à
ça.
C'est parce que on n'a pas obtenu, y
compris la loi bloche ne l'a pas fait,
que tout ça se traduise par des
dispositions contraignantes sur le droit
des rédactions
et et c'est ça qu'il faut obtenir
maintenant face à la concentration des
médias où 9 milliardaires contrôlent à
peu près l'ensemble la majorité du
paysage médiatique. Il faut obtenir des
barrières comme il faut obtenir des
règles sur les conflits d'intérêts. Par
exemple, il y a une proposition des
syndicats de journalistes et des
sociétés de journalistes sur le trafic
d'influence, un délit de trafic
d'influence. Quand on voit qu'un acteur
économique d'un média utilise son média
pour son influence
et qu'onarrive à le documenter et
ça s'appelle la philanthropie. Mais mais
mais et ça il faut il faut c'est que
l'écosystème médiatique français doit
être profondément revu dans la mesure où
en plus pour prendre les références
souvent qu'on a pris, nous n'avons pas
une culture libérale au sens anglo-saxon
du terme. Nous n'avons pas une culture
de balance de pouvoir. Nous n'avons pas
une culture d'équilibre de pouvoir. Il y
a un meilleur exemple, c'est plus bel
exemple, c'est actuellement il y a une
commission au Sénat sur la concentration
des médias. Les auditions sont
lamentables. Il faut comparer ça à des
earings au congrès américain ou queles
que soient les tendances, on a des gens,
ils ont plein de collaborateurs derrière
mais on passe un mauvais quart d'heure
et les questions sont fermées, sont
précises. Là, on est au café du commerce
et donc monsieur Vincent Boloré,
monsieur Bernard Arnaud, monsieur
Patrick Dra, monsieur Xavier Niel,
monsieur Martin Big, il se balade comme
c'est pas
ou complètement complètement. Mais alors
c'est parce que effectivement est-ce que
c'est parce qu'il y a pas la culture en
France parce que rien n'empêchait les
sénateurs qui ont mené les auditions de
travailler un peu lors dossier et
d'avoir des Mais effectivement tu avais
l'impression que c'était important de
briller parce que c'était filmé donc il
faisait des grandes déclarations bien
écrites et c'est c'est assez Alors moi
je suis archi pour qu'il y ait dans la
loi euh un dispositif qui protège
l'indépendance éditoriale des
journalistes je 120 % pour euh J'ai
l'impression qu' il existe des des bouts
d'éléments comme ça qui devraient nous
protéger. Ils ne sont jamais effectifs
parce qu'on va on en fait tu vas jamais
poursuivre ton employeur pour en gros
avoir exercé une pression sur toi pour
pas que tu diffuses un sujet et cetera.
et et je pense que il y a un moment où
dans l'histoire euh de de de des
relations entre les journalistes et leur
direction industrielle, je parle pas de
la direction éditoriale mais la
direction industrielle,
il faudrait qu'il y ait un réel conflit
qui aille jusqu'au terrain du juridique,
jusque devant les tribunaux. Et je pense
pas que ça a eu lieu jamais encore. La
dernière fois qu'il y a eu un
soulèvement sur le plan éditorial,
c'était ITV.
Ouais. 31 jours de grève, ils ont tous
été virés euh sans que personne lève le
petit doigt.
Pour ça qu'il faut il faut considérer
que c'est pas une question secondaire,
il faut se lever
la conscience d'un journaliste. Moi,
c'est une conversation que j'avais
parfois avec la direction de Canal, mais
moi j'ai un truc particulier. J'ai une
conscience, je suis un peu comme un un
tb un tout bib, il a le devoir
d'hypocrate, il peut pas faire de
l'expérimentation médicale avec toi
parce que ça t'intéresse. Moi, je je
peux pas mentir à au public parce que ça
va dans le sens de tes intérêts. Parce
que enfin, c'est des gens qui viennent
d' chaussé avant ils étaient à Procteur
et Gumble, ils disent "Bah non, toi tues
cadres, tu fais ce qu'on te dit quoi."
J'ai bah non, je suis journaliste, je
c'est ce que j'appelle l'absence de
culture démocratique et le pouvoir de
l'argent est un adversaire. Il y a un
texte formidable de Joseph Poulzer, on
connaît tous le prix de Poulzer et qui a
été un il a commencé à la base comme
journaliste et avec des scoops, hein. Il
a fait des scoops au début et puis il a
fait à l'américaine un success story et
tout et il fait un texte qui est il
existe, il a été publié en français sur
le journalisme pour convaincre
l'université de Colombia de faire la
première école de journalisme. Et c'est
un texte redoutable là-dessus et où il
dit il dit il dit que dès que tu sens
que des intérêts extérieurs à ton métier
viennent essayent de s'imposer à toi, tu
as rendez-vous avec ta liberté et toi
journaliste, avec tes principes et tu
dois et tu dois toi et avec ta
conscience. Et donc nous, je veux dire,
il y a pas et c'est pour ça que je
j'insiste sur le côté courageux. parfois
c'est une courageux collectivement.
C'estàd que c'est une un choix
individuel. Parfois on se retrouve
soi-même concerné et pris par ça. Mais
après, il faut mener des batailles
collectives. Et moi, j'ai le sentiment
plutôt aujourd'hui quand je vois
[grognement]
tout ce qu'on fait ensemble, comment ça
bouge, comment la nouvelle génération
bouge, comment tous ces médias
indépendants bougent. Le plus grand
syndicat d'éditeur de presse
aujourd'hui, c'est le syndicat qu'on a
cofondé, le syndicat de la presse
information d'indépendant en ligne par
le nombre de titres, par le nombre
d'entreprises de médias divers diverses,
petites et cetera, mais c'est là où ça
bouillonne, c'est là où ça invente,
c'est là où ça crée de nouveaux choses,
c'est là où ça invente, y compris des
choses dans l'aveuglement des autres,
les modèles économiques,
l'égalité entre papier et numérique,
toutes toutes sortes, le participatif
la créativité vidéo, la créativité
podcast, la créativité de de
l'interactivité. Donc tout ça, la
diffusion sur des multisupports. Donc
c'est c'est là qui qui est la nouveauté.
C'est ça qu'il faut accompagner. Et par
ailleurs, il y a une bataille politique.
Nous ce qu'on essaie c'est mettre à
l'agenda cette question face à des
politiques qui préfèrent
instrumentaliser les médias plutôt que
d'avoir un vrai système démocratique.
Alors euh on va encore faire parler
Louis parce que comme il va nous quitter
plutôt parce qu'il a une soirée vieux ce
soir. [grognement]
Non, c'est un anniversaire d'un d'un
confrère qui est plus âgé. C'est un
anniversaire qui est un bon confrère,
qui a une longue carrière, qui a été au
Canard enchaîné, qui a été au canard
enchaîné, qui a été à l'observateur, qui
est maintenant [grognement]
et qui traite une la région que connaît
bien Paul Paul Paul Morera, c'est René
Bachman qui est un formidable reporteur
international. Joyeux anniversaire René
et on a on doit le le fêter un compte
Twitter. Il a un compte Twitter ? S'il a
un compte Twitter là.
Oui, bien sûr qu'il a un compte Twitter.
Twitter. Bon, [rires] parenthèse,
d'accord. On arrête de faire les les
idéos 2 minutes. Imaginez-vous, vous
êtes journaliste d'investigation et là
vous tombez
sur une affaire d'État qui risque de
mettre tellement à mal la France par
rapport à d'autres puissances
que vous avez un dilemme.
Est-ce qu'il faut le sortir quit à
plomber l'économie française pour les 20
prochaines années ou est-ce qu'il faut
pas le sortir parce que vous êtes
patriote et que
et que voilà.
Donc Paul, vas-y.
En fait, moi je pense que quand tu
travailles à publier
euh
compris hein.
Oui oui oui. Quand tu travailles à
publier euh enfin c'est tu es face à ça
évidemment tu peux être faudrait que tu
me donnes un exemple précis mais a
priori tu es pas là pour défendre les
intérêts d'un état. Et si c'est de
l'ordre, si c'est de Non mais attends,
si c'est de l'ordre de l'intérêt public,
tu vois, si c'est quelque enfin prends
Wikileak par exemple, c'est un débat qui
a eu qui qui avait lieu euh euh au sein
de Wikileaks assez fréquemment où eux
ils avaient pris une position assez
radicale, ils disaient "On publie tout
et on filtre pas". C'était d'ailleurs,
il se vivait comme publisher plus que
comme journaliste. C'est une position
très radicale mais grâce à eux on a su
des trucs incroyable. Euh on on enfin
moi qui ai beaucoup été en Irak, je veux
dire que pour établir
un un un crime de guerre commis par
l'armée américaine et pourtant il y en a
eu des dizaines de milliers de morts,
c'était impossible. On était super
borné, on pouvait pas faire ce qu'on
voulait. Eux, ils diffusent la vidéo de
de de l'hélicoptère à qui abat les
notamment les deux journalistes de
Reuters et un certain nombre de civils
dont des gosses qui sont dans un
minivan. L'argument qu'on leur sort,
c'est l'argument que tu sors toi. Vous
êtes pas des journalistes. Non, non,
non, non, mais je toi tu fais tu c'est
non, c'est rétorique mais il leur dit
vous êtes pas des journalistes, vous
êtes des espions, vous mettez en danger
la sécurité nationale des États-Unis.
Par conséquent, on va vous poursuivre.
et Julia Lassange est enterré vivant ce
type dont enfin le seul crime est
d'avoir révélé des crimes de guerre de
l'armée américaine. Il est depuis 10 ans
11 ans maintenant entre l'ambassade
d'Équateur où il était enfermé et
maintenant la prison de Belle Marche. La
prison de Belle Marche et en attendant
une extradition enfin c'est quand même
le masque de fer de notre génération.
Moi, je suis vraiment ça me ça me sidère
tous les jours qu'on en fasse pas une
histoire centrale. Bien
sûr,
c'est hallucinant.
C'est le héros
de notre temps.
C'est le héros de notre génération.
Sinon, c'est que la France ne le protège
pas.
Personne le protège. Personne le
protège. Snoden.
Et Snowden on n pas offert l'asile à
Snowen et Chelsea Maning qui n'a a
refusé de réaccuser euh de participer à
l'accusation. Oui,
elle est d'un courage hallucinant
qui est la source. C'est la source,
c'est la source au départ de tout ça.
Elle refuse de jouer le jeu de de l'État
américain et elle dit "Je retourne en
prison." C'est un truc incroyable.
Je répondre cash à ta question. Si si on
se place du point de vue d'un état
démocratique, un état démocratique,
c'est pas l'état au-dessous de nous,
hein. L'état de droit, c'est les droits
des citoyens à faire valoir le droit.
C'est pas le droit des possesseurs de
l'État. Si on acceptait ton raisonnement
hypothétique, nous journalistes
travaillant dans un état démocratique en
ayant fait notre travail dans les règles
et tout, est-ce que c'est d'intérêt
public ? Est-ce que c'est vérifié et
tout ? Et bien ça veut dire que la
démocratie
baisserait son drapeau, ne serait pas
assez forte pour affronter la vérité et
deviendrait comme ce que demande
Poutine, ce que demande Erdogan, ce que
demande Chijinping. Pour ne prendre que
ces trois exemples, on ne peut pas nous
devons en démocratie avoir le courage
d'affronter la vérité, même la vérité
qui dérange nos intérêts nationaux. Même
la la vérité qui va nous obliger à
affronter un concert des nations où nous
ne sommes pas au-dessus des autres
nations, à affronter les critiques des
autres nations. Et moi, j'ai un cas.
Oui. C'est quoi l'affaire Green Pis ?
J'étais inconscient, j'allais j'avais 23
ans.
Le pouvoir m tout tout le monde entier
sait que c'est les services de
renseignement français qui ont fait c c
cet attentat contre cont 85 c'est mitant
c'est mitant c'est un ordre du pouvoir
politique contre le navire amiral du
mouvement Greenpeace on parle de
l'écologie aujourd'hui mais sous un
pouvoir de gauche on a fait un crime de
guerre un attentat sur ordre on a
demandé à des gens des services de
renseignement de faire exploser dans un
port ce bateau parce qu'il nous
dérangeait et manque de peau.
photographe Pereira est revenu dans dans
le bateau chercher ses appareils et il
en est mort.
La ligne du mensonge est choisie au cœur
de l'appareil d'État, au sommet en fait
contre ceux qui disaient notamment le
premier ministre et le ministre de
l'intérieur à l'époque, il disait "Non
mais il faut reconnaître qu'on a fait
une connerie et il faut commencer à
négocier avec les Néo-Zélandais. ça se
passait aux antipodes. Donc la ligne du
mensonge tient et la course
journalistique c'est que tout le monde a
compris qu'il y a un mensonge mais en
fait on n' pas la carte pour faire
tomber le château de carte du mensonge.
Les éléments qu'à la police néo
zélandaise ne permettent pas ne
permettent pas de mettre la main sur
ceux qui ont posé la bombe. C'est ce que
je vais appeler la troisème équipe qui
était composée de deux nageurs de combat
de l'armée française. Et sur ce
mensonge, du coup, on construit des
légendes. On l'a oublié mais à l'époque
c'était pas les réseaux sociaux, le
service public, la radio publique
française avec un journaliste infiltré
honorable correspondant de la DGSE, fait
scoop scoop du service public.
Comment il s'appelait ce
j'ai oublié son nom. Il a fait ensuite
il a fait les polars et tout mais ça a
été repris par sa hiérarchie. C'était un
scoop pendant le weekend hein. Non non
vous savez qui a fait le coup ? C'était
les anglais. C'était les anglais. La le
service public français dit c'était les
Anglais qui ont mis les bombes. Ce
document sonore est introuvable dans les
archives de Radio France. Il est caché,
on ne peut pas le trouver qu'il y a eu
des anniversaires de Greenpeace, les
journalistes ont essayé de le retrouver
pour me le faire écouter et cetera.
Introuvable. Donc les manipes étaient
là. Donc au sommet, c'est le mensonge
réitéré par Miteran qui envoie une
lettre avec toute la morgue au premier
ministre néo zélandais qui est qui était
travailliste. Donc la France était sur
l'idée et et si vous enquêtez là-dessus,
c'est que vous êtes un agent des
puissances étrangères, c'est que vous
êtes un espion d'où. C'est là commence
la la léanda négra contre la légende
noire me concernant. Et donc et et donc
ben bah ben non, il fallait il fallait
révéler, fallait faire tomber ce
mensonge. Fallait faire tomber ce
mensonge. Et là où je dis que depuis
longtemps on est une démocratie de basse
intensité dans toute autre démocratie
une puissance de moyenne d'impuissance.
Oui. Oui. Une une [rires]
mais dans toute autre démocratie le
parlement fait une commission d'enquête
après les révélations de cette ampleur.
Zéro commission d'enquête, zéro
curiosité. Mais je vais continuer
pendant ce temp pendant ce temps-là
campagne campagne dans le Figaro disant
la troisème équipe qui a révélé PLEL
n'existait pas Plel a été manipulé par
je sais pas quoi et cetera la troisème
équipe tout le monde sait j'ai même 30
ans après comme vieux lutteur convaincu
celui qui a posé les explosifs le
lieutenant colonel Kister de faire 1
heure filmer à Médiapart en présentant
ses excuses au peuple néoz-élandais
c'est un moment formidable parce que ce
sont des exécutants. Moi, j'ai défendu
les exécutants contre ceux qui ont donné
l'ordre. Mais je vais vous donner pour
montrer que c'est des vieilles vieilles
longueurs d'histoire. Le type qui est
dans le Figaro fait tous ses papiers
totalement bidons. Tous ces papiers
s'appelle Jean Bautorel. Jean Bautorel,
un ancien nationaliste breton plutôt de
droite. Et le nationaliste breton de
droite, ça a pas été pas toujours été
très sympathique notamment dans les
certains moments de du 20e siècle. Et
aujourd'hui, qui est Jean Boutorel ?
l'homme qui fait les bouquins à la
gloire du groupe Bolloré en Bretagne et
qui fait la légende du groupe Bolloré en
Bretagne. Pour ça, quand tu as dit le
vieux tout à l'heure, ben il y a parfois
une certaine longueur qui permet de
comprendre comprendre d'où ça vient tout
ça. Donc voilà. Oui, bien sûr.
Juste revenir parce que ta question est
tellement brutale que j'ai fallait un
certain temps pour [rires] la
métaboliser. Je voudrais revenir sur le
la Côte d'Ivoire parce que pour moi
c'est un moment fondateur,
tu vois. Nous, on a la preuve que
l'armée française a ouvert le feu sur
des civils. C'est un crime de guerre. Il
y a 15 morts. C'est un crime de guerre.
On alors on se dit il faut le révéler.
Et là, je me retrouve face à des gens de
bonne fois, franchement, je les condamne
pas, qui me disent "Les expats français
sont déjà en grande difficulté. Si
jamais tu sors ça, tu auras des morts
sur la conscience le lendemain."
Qu'est-ce que j'ai dis ? "Ouais, mais
attends, on va pas le dissimuler, c'est
pas possible." Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
On diffuse ça et la pression tombe.
C'est le contraire qui se passe parce
qu'en fait la vérité c'est aussi un
effet de justice. Ces gens qui tu vois
dont la dont la souffrance n'était pas
reconnue, ça augmente la haine en fait
et et en fait de sortir la vérité, tu tu
fais souvent tomber la pression. En tout
cas dans ces histoires où où le sang des
civils est versé.
On reprendra cette conversation juste
après que je
donne confiance aussi parce que je vois
la désespérance qu'il y a par rapport à
notre vie publique, l'abstention et
cetera, y compris le compliment que tu
nous as fait tout à l'heure. Quel que
soit, je veux dire, c'est pas une
question personnelle vis-à-vis de nous.
Je pense qu'il y a aussi quelque chose
qui se joue dans le rapport au métier et
qui fait notre conflit avec d'autres en
haut, y compris dans notre profession.
C'est que paradoxalement, nous on apaise
la démocratie, on redonne confiance. Ça
dit mais quand même il y a des gens qui
peuvent dire les choses. Prends prends
la crise sanitaire. La crise sanitaire
quand on fait les révélations il y a 2
ans sur la pénurie de masque qui ont
fait qui ont été énormes. C'est que il
faut rappeler quand même la folie dans
laquelle était ce pouvoir à l'époque le
ridicule dans lequel leur mensonge les a
amené. Si Ben qui dit je ne sais pas à
quoi ça sert et je ne sais même pas
comment propager la panique
voilà mais je ne sais même pas comment
on le met. la ministre de la santé qui
va faire la campagne électorale à Paris
alors qu'elle devrait être sur le pont.
la conseillère de l'Élysée qui part avec
essayer de faire la campagne de son de
son mari à la mairie de Strasbourg et
obtenir un poste d'ambassadeur. Enfin,
une sorte de déliquence et ils savent
tous
et notamment certains de ceux qui sont
acteurs parce qu'ils étaient autour de
Marisol Touren, la ministre de la santé
qui aujourd'hui a rejoint le camp
Macron, ils savent tous qu'ils ont
commis cette erreur de détruire les
stocks stratégiques de masque. Le court
terme, hein, ce que disaient les
rapports, c'est que justement ces stocks
stratégies de masque en en risque de
pandémie, il ne faut pas raisonner en
terme de rentabilité, faut raisonner en
terme justement de bien public et ça
c'est pas un tableau Excel d'un
financier qui permet ça. Donc quand on
fait ça, et bien on permet que soit
ouvert le débat sur qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'une politique sanitaire. Et dans la
foulée, le président du conseil
scientifique fait un rapport formidable
sur le thème on ne fait pas une
politique sanitaire contre la
population, on fait une politique
sanitaire avec les premiers concernés
sur qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une
démocratie sanitaire. Donc d'une
certaine manière, je je Paul a a
vraiment mis le doigt dessus, c'est la
vérité est apaisante. La vérité parfois
il nous fait mal nous quand on la trouve
parce qu'elle est dure à voir et parfois
il y a des doutes, il y a des
interrogations sur notre responsabilité,
il y a même comment dire des
déchirements parce que moi je n'ai pas
ça ne m'amuse pas de montrer que il y a
une telle dimension de mensonge. Je vais
raconter ici même une anecdote. Ouais,
mais alors un quart d'heure de plus.
Non, mais juste une anecdote. François
Fillon, moi j'ai connu François Fillon,
ministre de l'éducation et proche euh de
ce représentant de de la la gauche la
gauche la le gaulisme, pas la gauche par
exemple, le gaolisme social euh autour
de Philippe Séin et cetera. Bon,
fait Philippe Se
fait Philippe Sega quand il est choisi,
il sort en surprise à la primaire des de
la droite, je dit à l'équipe de
Médiapar, bon OK, on sera en désaccord
avec lui et tout, mais vous allez voir.
Bon, c'est la droite civilisée,
c'est la droite civilisée. Bon, le
ridicule ne tue pas. Bon voilà et et on
se on découvre que ce type qui avait dit
euh on n'imagine pas le général de
Gaulle mise en examen à SarkoZi qui se
présentait comme du côté euh justement
du gaulisme soucieux d'égalité et tout
est un homme à vide d'argent jusqu'à se
vendre à Poutine aujourd'hui. Voilà se
dit mais mais comment est-ce possible ?
Bah donc voilà évidemment que moi je
suis pas heureux de trouver ça. Je suis
pas
se vend se vendre à Poutine parce qu'on
lui a pas proposé de boulot en France.
Non mais d'accord. Non, néanmoins
mais mais je suis désolé si tu as
prétendu défendre l'intérêt général.
Même s'il allait chez Total, même s'il
allait chez Total ou sur une autre
entreprise que polluante et cetera, ce
que je veux dire c'est que tu choisis le
business, tu choisis l'argent, tu
choisis pas. Tu imagines Pierre Mind
France avoir fait ça, tu imagines
Charles de Gaulle avoir fait ça, tu
enfin voilà, c'est quand même je prends
des histoires de ma génération mais je
pourrais dire "Tu imagines Lionel Jospin
faire ça ? Tu imagines Pierre Joc faire
ça pour prendre génération de gauche
plus récente. Voilà. Henri Krazuki faire
ça.
Leader de la CGT. Oui. George George
Marchet. Bon, c'est une autre histoire
mais mais [rires]
mais donc voilà donc il y a pas on n'est
pas on se réjouit pas de ça. C'est pas
du tir au pigeon ce qu'on fait. C'est
pas voilà. Mais par ailleurs, je pense
qu'il y a il y a une il y a c'est aussi
vieux que l'Ecclésiaste. Il faut
regarder la vérité en face. et pas
tomber dans le piège des Gorgones où on
est totalement paralysé. Faut une vérité
émancipatrice.
Comme il nous reste un tout petit peu de
temps avecoui, on va on va
Non mais c'est pas grave.
Mais médiia crash, il faut
la concentration la concent parce que là
on a craché les journalistes un peu.
La concentration des médias c'est bien,
c'est pas bien, c'est de la
philanthropie,
c'est quoi ? Tu as du mal à poser la
question en ayant l'air d'y croire quand
même. [rires]
C'est quoi cette question ? Alors allez
voir Media Crash à la réponse à ta
question. Non non, ça ça craint. Et et
il y a il y a le le le cauchemar qui se
profile de la fusion TF1 M6. C'est chaud
quand même. C'estd que c'est le c'est en
fait plus ça concentre moins il y a de
pluralisme. Évidemment, il restera
toujours le net et mais c'est pas la
même force de frappe financière quoi.
Donc non, c'est un moment difficile.
Lucerman et Valentine Auerty avec les
équipes de première ligne et de de
Médiapart ont réussi un tour de force
parce que ça a été fait comme un film
d'intervention hein. On a fait ça vite.
On neprét pas révolutionner le cinéma,
mais on voulait le sortir là pour avoir
notre propre agenda, notre agenda
citoyen indépendamment de la course des
petits chevaux présidentiels. Et du
coup, c'est ce qui se passe. C'est pour
ça que c'est en salle hein, c'est en
salle, c'est des débats en salle, c'est
des rencontres en salle, c'est des
discussions où il y a beaucoup de jeunes
et et qui posent ce problème là.
C'est-à-dire que la formation, c'est pas
une marchandise comme les autres. et et
justement ça doit être protégé ça doit
être bien public
ça doit être protégé du capital mais
c'est pas révolutionnaire de dire ça
c'est Albert Camu Albert Camu à la
libération de Paris quand il a vu la la
dégradation de la presse de l'entre de
guerre et ce qu'elle a produit je
rappelle qu'il y avait un type il était
parfumeur il était richissime il a
acheté le Figaro et il en a fait un
journal fasciste. Il s'appelait François
Cotti et il a financé l'action française
Charles Mor, Léon Deodet et donc ce qui
va donner le péténnisme donc tout ça.
Pendant le même temps, il y avait des
gens qui manipulaient l'actionnariat du
journal de référence le temps et du coup
un jour Hubert Buerry, le futur patron
du monde s'est rendu compte qu'ils
avaient qu'ils avaient été vendus avec
les chaises, avec les bureaux, hein.
Donc et et il dira il dira dans des
conférences sur la presse et l'argent
Hubert Buery combien ce souvenir comme
un peu ton souvenir de la Côte d'Ivoire
à Canal et comme une empreinte et il
parlait de cette saloperie lui qui était
pas du genre à à utiliser ce langage là.
Et donc nous sommes face à ça. Nous
sommes face à un mélange d'intérêt des
gens qui achètent quelque chose
[grognement] qui est d'intérêt public
pour se protéger, pour protéger les
leurs et pour influencer en cachant des
choses. Vous verrez quand même. Moi j'ai
c'est un film d'enquête ce qu'on fait
Luc et Valentine, c'est pas du
[grognement] blab blabla, c'est pas du
commentaire, ça montre des réalité mais
quand on voit la brutalité de gens mais
quand on entend, moi je le connaissais
pas cette séquence, Bernard Arnaud, le
premier l'homme le plus riche de France,
d'Europe, la 3è fortune mondiale, le
numéro 1 mondial du luxe, menacer un
confrère de la télévision publique,
menacé d'avoir un dossier sur lui,
menacé que ce dossier puisse être révélé
et de fait c'est ce qui se passera. Ils
vont déposer plainte contre lui pour
extorsion de fond sur une barbouserie
totalement fausse totalement inventé. Il
devra aller deux fois être entendu par
la police. Il raconte ça ce confrère
avec beaucoup de philosophie, beaucoup
de Je vais prendre sa défense, je vais
faire l'avocat du diable. Il s'est fait
intoxiquer par ses mauvais
communiquants.
Non, dans le film, on découvre qu'il est
pas du tout intoxiqué quand c'est lui
qui donne les consignes. L'ancien chef
des services de renseignement français
qui a été se vendre. Squarini dit le
squal
prestataire.
Voilà.
Très drôle en plus savoureuse. C'est un
des moments on rigole le plus dans le
film. On dort de la gravité du truc. On
a essayé de le rendre
rigolo. C'est d'être un peu comme Carl
Crot. C'est on se dit que l'humour et
peut accompagner la vérité et être
inflammatoire.
Iloui continue.
Carl Cross. Non mais je pensais quand il
parlait de Carl Cross, Carl Cross
c'était une figure de de de ce monde
disparu. Il est décédé dans les années
30 et au fond, il avait fait un journal
dont il était le seul rédacteur qui
était pour tirer à Boulet Rouge sur la
presse. C'était ça et c'était le
langage. Et notamment pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale. Attention, la
guerre revient.
Elle est dans le paysage. Elle était là
déjà. Si on est syrien, on sait qu'il
était minuit dans le siècle déjà hein.
Ils sont déjà passés par minuit dans le
siècle.
Je peux mettre une parenthèse ? Quand il
y a Eddard Sloden qui tweet, il y a rien
de plus euh
comment c'était la formulation ? Il dit
combien la que des médias qui appellent
à la guerre.
Il y a rien de plus pathétique que des
médias qui app guerre. Et on pourrait y
ajouter la phrase célèbre d'un
correspondant de guerre en 141 en disant
la première victime de la guerre c'est
la vérité. C'est la vérité. Les
propagandes auront lieu des deux bords.
On a démonté par exemple une vidéo que
les services russes ont essayé de
diffuser, enfin ont diffusé qui était
une vidéo prétendant une agression une
agression
ukrainienne et en fait toutes les
métadonnées de la vidéo ont permis de
montrer que c'était le traficage d'une
vidéo faite 15 jours avant et cetera.
Mais il peut y avoir des intoxes de
l'autre côté. Mais dans un dans un
moment comme ça et on en revient à ta
question sur est-ce qu'on a une ligne
patriotique ? Est-ce qu'on a une ligne
et cetera ? On a une ligne qui est le
devoir d'informer.
Alors, je coupe par rapport à la ligne
question d'internet qui n'est pas une
question si qui est une question fence
act de 2006. Vous voyez ce que c'est ?
C'est construire un mur à la frontière
mexicaine.
Ah oui,
OK. De 2006. Méia part de points. Trump
proclame l'urgence nationale pour
construire son mur. C'est juste une
erreur ou c'est une fake news ? Je sais
pas si c'est un titre de nous
c'est un titre de vous. J'ai le titre
Trump proclame l'urgence nationale pour
construire son mur. Donald Trump a
décidé.
Bien sûr, c'est son c'est c'est tout à
fait vrai. C'était le mur de Trump.
C'est pas le mur de Trump. Ça a été
décidé en 2006. Moi, j'étais à la
frontière mexicaine, je posais la
question aux Mexicains ce que ça leur
faisait d'avoir un truc qui se
construisait et il me disait "Putain,
c'est vachement bien, on fait
l'aller-retour, on prend 1500 dollars."
Non, mais ça, il faudrait que je vois
cet article parce que là comme ça, je je
enfin je nous savons tous quand même que
Trump a accéléré, a construit et a
investi pour construire ce mur à la
frontière mexicaine sous sa présidence
depuis 2006. Non, mais que ce soit prévu
dans le débat par les majorités
républicaines, par des discussions par
et cetera et que il y ait des démocrates
qui soient aussi y compris sous la
présidence actuelle dans une politique
d'immigration, je comprends pas bien le
sens de la question
parce toujours eu un mur. Moi je je l'ai
vu en 95, je l'ai vu à San Diego, il y
avait un mur. Mais en plus 2006, Trump
ça colle pas parce que c'est
non ça colle pas. C'estd que c'est pas
son mur.
Non mais moi je je nous n'existions pas
en 2006 donc c'est pour ça que je vous
en comprends pas. Je je c'est pour ça
que je encore une fois je pense qu'il y
a un mélange entre deux choses. Nous
nous n'existions pas entre 2006 donc
2016 pardon.
Ben c'est 2016 donc voilà donc voilà
donc nous sommes bien sous la présidence
Trump là. Mais attention, dans ces
questions-là, nous sommes dans un
moment, attention où je le vois dans
beaucoup de commentaires où de la même
manière qu'il y a ces réactions
partisanes dont on parlait tout à
l'heure, tout à l'heure [grognement] en
France par rapport à nos informations,
il y a des réactions campistes
aujourd'hui
adopté le 14 septembre 2006. D'accord.
Oui. Attends, je reviens
par 280 voix sur 138.
Mais je là, nous parlons de notre
article sur ce que faisait la présidence
Trump, hein. OK. Mais je reviens aussi
parce que je devine qu'il y a peut-être
ça derrière le sens de la question. Il y
a il y a il y a des lectures aujourd'hui
campistes. C'est-à-dire que nous on
tient les debouts. Nous on tient les
debouts. Nous on pense que Poutine être
journaliste chez Poutine, nous on survit
pas 2 secondes. On est en tôle où on est
assassiné. Faut quand même le dire. Faut
dire Poutine c'est pas c'est pas le une
culture démocratique avec laquelle on
discute.
Mais non d'accord [raclement de gorge]
c'est pas la même intensité. Je suis
désolé hein, on n'est pas Anna
Politovskaya assassiné. On n'est pas ce
qui se passe quand on couvrait la guerre
en Tchenie et on n'est pas et les
opposants politiques eux-mêmes et les
compromates et les vidéos pour ouis la
compromission pour essayer de te te
balancer des légendes de calomnie qu'il
y a sur nous sur les réseaux sociaux, ça
prend une autre consistance. Donc on est
dans une autre histoire quand même. Donc
je veux dire faut pas barguer avec ça et
on peut pas regarder ça rationnellement.
Je veux dire, il faut regarder ça
rationnellement. Ça ne nous empêche pas
d'essayer de comprendre d'essayer de
comprendre toute cette histoire comment
comment de l'autre côté depuis la chute
du mur et la fin de l'Union soviétique,
il y a eu des logiques de puissance qui
n'ont pas construit un nouvel équilibre
avec la Russie, n'ont pas construit de
nouvelles passerelles avec la Russie.
Mais par ailleurs, encore une fois, euh
il y a il y a une sorte de pavlovisme
dans le débat public français qui existe
et qui et qui et qui épouse quelque
chose qui n'est pas n'est pas n'est pas
forcément de gauche et qui a une longue
histoire française qui vient de la
droite de l'extrême droite qui est
l'anti-américanisme primaire, hein. Moi
je voilà et et je dis ça parce que tout
de suite on regarde ça en logique hein.
Est-ce que Media Part a a a
cogné sur Trump ? Trump, il s'est
félicité hein de Poutine là et l'extrême
droite française est avec Poutine là.
Donc ça donne une lecture quand même de
ce qui se passe. De toute façon, on sait
tous que Méia part c'est communiste.
Paul [rires]
non c'est
c'est le Mossade.
Non
c'est la DGS.
Non non non non. C'est la ligne de
chemin de fer dont parlait le camarade
tout à l'heure.
C'est les journalistes.
Camarad pire. t lesjournalistes, tu sais
dans toutes ces régimes dans je suis
d'accord avec toi, le cours autoritaire
et et y compris le phénomène nouveau,
c'est des démocraties autoritaire, des
pouvoirs issus du vote qui violent qui
violent les droits fondamentaux et on
l'a vu y compris dans la répression du
droit de manifester, la répression des
gilets jaunes, la répression des
journalistes et cetera. Mais tu vois
bien que dans ce moment-là, tu le vois
et c'est pareil dans toute l'attitude,
les premières cibles, c'est pas les
opposants politiques, c'est les
journalistes indépendants.
Non, mais je suis entièrement d'accord
que être journaliste en en Russie, c'est
compliqué, mais en France, c'est
compliqué aussi. En France, on vous tire
pas une balle dans la tête tout de suite
parce que ça fait mauvais genre quand
même.
Jamais, jamais. À mon souvenir, il y a
jamais eu un journaliste tué en France.
Si il y a eu la réda d'action de Charlie
Hebdo, faut quand même dire que le
pouvoir
là le journaliste, imagine un cas
d'école, un jeune journaliste dans une
rédaction veut publier un truc et là il
se fait repérer comme un élément
perturbateur, un troublon, un quelqu'un
qui veut pas s'aligner. On va pas lui
tirer une balle en France. Bah on va le
virer.
On va le virer. Bah, tu
sais, moi une fois Attends, attends, on
va on va le faire crever parce que il va
stresser parce qu'il peut pas payer son
crédit, le crédit de sa voiture, les
études de ses enfants et c'est une
petite mort, un petit feu. C'est pareil
aujourd'hui. Aujourd'hui, il a plein
d'endroit. Une fois j'étais il y a une
jeune une école de journalisme qui m'a
proposé d'être parin donc de leur de
leur gén promotion, je sais plus comment
ça et il fallait que je fasse un petit
discours et euh et donc j'ai fait un
discours qui s'appelait éloge du
licenciement et en fait c'est un métier
où il faut rentrer en se disant que
l'impermanence est notre règle. Si tu te
dis je vais faire carrière, je vais
regarder le pli de mon costard, voir si
mon fauteuil va bien, donner des Non,
ben non. Bah faut pas faire ce métier
là, il faut le faire en se disant notre
durée de vie est impermanente parce que
à un moment donné tu vas rencontrer la
dure, tu vois le mur quoi. Et
comment construire une vie avec une
femme, des enfants, excuse-moi,
excuse-moi. Des ouvriers qui se font
licencier, ça existe aussi. Il faut se
battre hein, faut se battre dans tous
les métiers hein. Et et voilà, faut se
battre et bien
et et se battre collectivement et voilà.
Donc et savoir que le collectif est et
le collectif est à meilleure protection
et par ailleurs bon voilà et nous on est
témoin du fait que oui, comment dire il
y a un film illusion perdue à partir des
des illusions perdues de Balzac en salle
qui raconte les corruptions du
journalisme. C'est vieux comme le
journalisme hein c'estes tentations. Tu
as des idéaux et puis à un moment on te
tente, on te tente et on te tente et on
te donne plein de raisons y compris ton
crédit à la fin du mois, y compris ta
notoriété y compris et cetera. Donc
c'est un peu triste. C'est vrai que à un
certain âge, tu te dis "J'en ai vu pas
mal passer comme dans Star Wars du côté
obscur de la force." OK. Bon ben voilà
bah il faut il faut des Jedi. Jed Yod,
[rires] un conseil un conseil pour les
jeunes générations et trois bouquins
avant de décrocher le micro de le
laisser sur la HS pour qu'on continue
l'inter.
Non mais il faut faut faut résister faut
résister c'est
alors tout d'abord trois bouquins.
Trois bouquins. Trois bouquins comme ça
spontanément. Ah ben je sais pas moi je
euh
alors trois bouquins comme ça comme ça
trois bouquins parce que il y en a plein
donc je dire moi chercher mais je savais
pas non mais tu comprends tu dis il y en
a plein pourquoi je choisirais celui-là
tel autre et tout j'ai parlé sur le
journaliste de Poulitzer donc on va
recommander sur le journaliste de
Poulitzer on va recommander Terre des
Ben d'Albertlonde. C'est là où il
commence, il dit "On m'a traité de tous
les noms de justement d'ennemis de la
patrie parce qu'il montre que la France
universelle viole ses droits, prétention
universel viole ses droits avec le
travail forcé. C'est là où il termine.
Notre métier n'est pas de faire plaisir
non plus de faire du tort, il est de
porter la plume dans la plie. Voilà donc
Terre des Ben le 3e et le 2e et le 3e
qui pourrait être un un récit euh
formidable d'un voilà ben le livre de
Snowden. Peut-être le livre de Snowden
pour euh parce que Snowden c'est une
belle figure parce que il est en otage
là-bas d'une certaine manière où on l'a
laissé
en otage, il est en otage des
États-Unis.
Oui, il est en otage mais en même temps,
je veux dire parce que nous nous ne lui
proposons pas l'accueil et en même temps
il est arrêté là-bas. Parce que je
voudrais signaler son courage hein,
c'est que il fait sur les réseaux
sociaux des critiques du pouvoir de
Poutine hein, il le fait hein, il n'est
pas aligné, il voilà donc Snowden parce
que
il est protégé H24 par les services de
renseignement russes.
Oui oui oui oui oui. Mais protégé ou ou
coucouné, [rires] c'est les deux.
Attention moi je me ferai pas Voilà,
c'est c'est ambigu tout ça. Les services
de renseignement quand ils protègent,
ils se renseignent aussi. Ils font les
deux métiers. Et je dis ça
pour les jeunes générations.
Je dis ça B je l'ai dit tout à l'heure,
je pense que voilà, il faut il faut
résister et puis moi je me suis fait un
mantra à moi, l'inquiétude et
l'antichambre de l'espérance. Donc en
s'inquiétant,
il y a un premier petit bietin qui qui
dit à peu près la même chose. Ouais.
Quand vous avez un problème
et que vous avez une solution, ça sert à
rien de s'inquiéter. Mais quand vous
avez un problème et que vous n'avez pas
de solution, ça sert à rien de
s'inquiéter encore plus. Allez, hop,
dehors.
Bon, merci. Allez. Faut pas l'oublier
les clés, le portefeuille. On va rester
avec Paul.
C'était une garde à vue. Reprenez. On
lui on lui a laissé on lui a laissé s
laer. On est sympa.
Merci encore.
Euh caméra sur Paul. Attention pas les
les Oui, pas de proteste de H ce soir.
Ciao. Ciao. [grognement]
Bye bye.
Merci encore Edoui
Paul.
Ouais.
Comment ça va ? Bah écoute, très bien.
Je suis très content d'être parmi nous.
E nous aussi d'ailleurs, c'est ça fait
vraiment plaisir. La dernière interview
euh ça remontaé à très longtemps,
2016 je crois. Ouais.
Dans ces
je revenais de Falouja, je me rappelle.
Ouais.
C'est ça calme hein
le le la vision sur les médias, notre
démocratie, le rôle des journalistes,
l'énergie.
Euh qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire à cette
jeune génération qui va se retrouver
dans un climat qui ressemble à Média
Crash, une concentration extrême de des
médias, des fusions, acquisition dans
les autres et on va dire le petit étard
journaliste
h
qui qui voit deux deux mougoules de le
de la presse dire faut résister, faut
pas prendre de crédit, ça va être
compliqué avec ta femme, ça va être
compliqué avec ton ulcère de l'estomac,
Tu vas perdre tes dents parce que tu vas
grincer les dents. C'était dit entre les
lignes là.
Ouais. Ouais. Mais je comprends tout à
fait ta question et euh
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui être jeune
journaliste tuarrives sur le avec enfin
si tu as envie euh et la plupart des
jeunes journalistes ont envie de mener
ce métier avec
l'isme, passion, tout ça, ben les champs
sont réduits. Du côté de la presse
écrite. C'est quand même très très
enfin ça embauche pas, on va dire. Et du
côté de la télévision,
les chaînes qui diffusent des sujets
dont on peut être fier, elles sont pas
très nombreuses, hein. C'est le service
public
et maintenant un peu quand même Netflix.
On bosse pour Netflix et on découvre un
monde où c'est pas impossible d'être
libre à condition qu'on respecte
les codes de la dramaturgie, du
suspense, du clive, de tous ces
trucs-là. Mais il y a un petit espace
pour la liberté. Je pense que mais le
problème c'est qu'il y a pas de modèle
économique enfin médiia part ils en ont
inventé un mais je pense que vraiment
dans le numérique
quelque chose va survenir. Je vois de
plus en plus de monde qui font appel à
euh des
cagnotes voilà et cetera et qui et qui
font des films qui les mettent sur
YouTube. Il y a Off investigation, il y
a euh il y a il y a une myiade de de de
sites qui existent. Euh on on pourrait
imaginer pas immédiatement hein parce
que là on est dans un entre deux
effectivement un peu désespérant quoi.
Alors je une parenthèse sur Off
investigation.
On devait le recevoir mais son attaché
de presse nous a dit euh si vous nous
garantissez euh on vous enverra le
bouquin si vous nous garantissez une
interview derrière et moi je lui ai dit
le dernier mec qui m'a dit ici il a pas
passé la porte donc personne nous donne
des conditions quoi que ce soit. Donc on
n pas fait offigation uniquement à cause
de la tâché de presse.
C'est bizarre
parce que on nous met on nous met pas de
conditions et et c'est dommage. Désolé
d'avoir coupé.
Non non mais enfin voilà, c'est ce que
ce que je pense c'est c'est ça c'est que
enfin moi quand j'ai commencé à faire de
la télévision, il y avait par exemple il
y avait Canal qui absorbait une quantité
de sujets libres euh ou relativement
libre. On n'est jamais libre. Il y avait
une phrase dans le bureau de de de
greffe qui disait "On n'est jamais aussi
libre que enfin la on mesure sa liberté
à la longueur de la chaîne." Et c'était
un peu ça
l'attention sur le collier.
Voilà. Et la chaîne était longue donc
bon c'était quand même mieux que rien.
Mais oui là en fait il reste voilà le
service public est harté c'est trois
petits guichets étroits et des centaines
et des milliers de personnes qui veulent
bosser. C'est on est à un moment
[soupir] franchement j'encouragerai pas
un jeune à à devenir journaliste là tout
de suite quoi. Même s'il y a des tas en
fait il y a des tas de médias que je
trouve absolument épats. Je sais pas je
pourrais je pourrais passer la soirée à
vous êtes bien street press c'est bien
médiia part évidemment c'est très bien.
Il y a des kilotonnes de petites niches
qui avec trois bouts de ficelles
arrivent à faire exister une parole
différente. Mais il y a pas encore ni le
truc à intercept, tu vois. Enfin, il
manque en fait, il manque un
milliardaire éclairé.
Pierre média aux États-Unis qui se dit
"Bon, je pense que du journalisme
d'investigation radicale est indépendant
et indépendant et et et
[raclement de gorge] fondamental pour ce
pays, pour les États-Unis et il va
financer de 250 millions de de dollars
de sa poche, peut-être le meilleur site
d'investigation américain des
Intercept." Mais
façon de se racheter parce qu'on dit
toujours on dit on dit toujours que
derrière toute grande fortune,
il y a du sang de pauvre.
Il y a un crime. C'est ce que disait
Balzac. Derrière toute grande fortune,
il y a un crime. C'est possible ça.
C'est eBay quoi. Le mec a créé ça. Ça a
cartonné. Il y avait un autre gars,
c'est le gars qui avait créé le palme.
[raclement de gorge] Tu te souviens du
palme ? L'ancêtre de
et euh
palmo
Voilà.
C'est ça. Le truc en monochrome vert.
Ouais, mais c'est des années 90. et il a
fait fortune et il a il a dépensé une
grande partie de sa fortune à payer des
fondations de journalisme
d'investigation. C'était à la même
époque du PSI qui éétait pas euh euh
avec les
c'était pas le même le palion. Non,
c'était le pion. Le pson, il y a un
petit cier quand même.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a pu faire de conneries
sur Psion ? [rires] Non, de toute façon.
Non mais voilà, enfin il y a pas il y a
pas de milliardaires éclairés avec la
volonté de créer des contrepouvoirs. Ça
on dirait que ça n'existe pas. Les
milliardaires qu'on a, c'est Boloré,
Arnaud, Pinot, enfin, ils ont absolument
pas cet agenda là. Ils sont pour la
protection du statut co. Il y a pas,
enfin moi j'ai le souvenir, tu dois être
suffisamment vieux pour t'en souvenir
aussi d'un mec comme Jean-François
Biseau qui au fond était une figure
comme ça. C'était un type qui était
assis sur une fortune familiale
incroyable et qui avait créé Actuel et
Nova sur ses sous. Bon, en essayant de
créer un petit modèle économique.
Nova la radio.
Nova la radio. Ouais. Il y a une autre
Nova non Nova la radio et le magazine
actuel dont les plus anciens se
souviennent peut-être qui était un
magazine dit de contreculture mais qui
en fait était assez mainstream à une
époque puisquil vendait jusqu'à 400000
exemplaires. Bah des figures comme ça en
France n'existent pas.
C'est dommage.
On a la chance d'avoir Paul Morera qui a
voyagé un peu partout dans le monde, qui
a fait des documentaires. Là, il y a
beaucoup de questions sur il y a des
questions sur la géopolitique.
Comment il voit Paul Morera la
géopolitique mondiale à l'heure actuelle
?
Ou ça c'est large comme question.
Il y en a une qui est un peu plus
pointu. Paul Morera, Ukraine, les
masques de la révolution. Envie de
revenir dessus au vu du contexte actuel.
Les masques de la révolution. Oui. Donc
c'est un film que j'ai réalisé en
ou 2016 sur les groupe néonazis
[raclement de gorge] qui paramilitaire
qui euh il
y a pas que ça en Ukraine.
Non non, il y a pas que ça en Ukraine
mais qui était présent en Ukraine qui
était en fait qui qui était comme une
sorte de
c'est comme un chancre dans le pouvoir
quoi. que le le le gouvernement se
rendait bien compte qu'ils avaient ces
types
extrêmement gênants, extrêmement
violents, extrêmement gênant du point de
vue de l'image. Ils essayaient pour
certains d'entre eux de les contenir, de
négocier avec eux, parfois d'en arrêter
un de temps en temps. J'avais pu filmer
l'arrestation de l'un d'entre eux,
Mozichu qui s'appelait l'arrestation au
parlement de de d'un de ses chefs de
milice.
C'était assez spectaculaire de de devant
nos caméras, mais en gros quand même le
problème n'est pas résolu. Alors là, on
est en plein dans une offensive
militaire et et et politique des Russes
sur l'Ukraine, mais le problème n'est
pas résolu. Le le la brigade Azov qui
est une brigade menée par des néonazis,
elle existe toujours. Elle s'est formée
en bataillon, elle a grandi. Pravis
sector à ma connaissance doit toujours
exister. Donc c'est c'est un problème
qui n'est pas résolu euh et ça c'est pas
uniquement de la propagande russe parce
que c'est vrai que la propagande russe
ça l'arrange de dire que il y a des
groupes néonazis en Ukraine. Mais enfin
si vous voyez Belling Cat qui est un un
média dont on peut pas soupçonner qu'il
soit prousse, ils ont fait des enquêtes
approfondies sur comment ce ce ces ces
ces milices néonazies sont devenues un
hub pour pour tous les néonazies de la
planète quoi. c'est que le mec qui a
commis le le le meurtres à Christ
Church, il était passé il était passé
par l'Ukraine. Encore une fois, ça ne
veut pas dire que le pouvoir ukrainien
soit sous le contrôle des néonazies.
Absolument pas. Mais ça veut dire qu'ils
ont pas réussi à résoudre le problème,
que ces ces forces qui sont des forces
armées sont toujours là et que elles
sont elles ont pas été suffisamment
challengées à mon sens. Maintenant, on
est dans un moment où euh Poutine lance
une offensive qui pour l'instant me
semble plutôt être une offensive de
communication euh dans la mesure où en
fait il a envahi des territoires qui
étaient déjà sous son contrôle. C'est un
truc un peu théâtral quoi. Quand quand
tu vois quand il a lancé le truc, il dit
"Ouais, je reconnais Louans que enfin je
reconnais Don le Donbas tout ça
et euh mais mais en fait il c'est des
zones qui ont toujours été sous son
contrôle. Alors là il dit que le le
Donbas ça va ça ça inclut Odessa et
cetera. Bon, on est dans la divination.
Moi, quand je quand je vois Poutine,
je l'ai vu cette séance incroyable où il
fait le tour de son conseil de sécurité,
où il passe à la question là le le
responsable de ses services de sécurité.
Il bug, il bug.
Ouais, le mec bug. Et et là, c'est drôle
parce que Poutine,
c'est évidemment un autocrate, mais euh
je j'ai toujours eu le sentiment qu'il
était assez maître de lui pour essayer
de donner le donner le de donner le
change comme si c'était un peu certains
autocrates un peu mais quand même qu'il
veut jouer le jeu de la démocratie. Et
là, pour la première fois, j'ai
l'impression queil a complètement fait
tomber le masque et on voit vraiment un
truc qui est entre un mélange de de
dictateur et de chef de milice quoi où
vraiment il fait peur. Il fait peur à
son chef des services secrets. Il dit
"Mais mais parlez parlez enfin, il faut
la il faut voir vraiment cette image euh
parce que je trouve qu'elle est assez
parlante sur quelque chose qui s'est
passé dans la tête de Poutine. Le
correspondant du New York Times à Moscou
a publié un papier très intéressant,
pure supputation, où il dit "On se tu
journaliste, c'est ça ?" Oui. Oui. Non,
mais là, il le dit hein. Il dit "En
fait, j'en sais rien. C'est tellement
bizarre ce qu'il est en train de faire
qu'une des suputations qui qui traitent
à Moscou, c'est on sait que Poutine a
passé tout le Covid extrêmement
retranché du monde et des gens se
demandent si ça a pas fini par lui taper
sur le ciboulot, si on n'est pas dans
une espèce de post-traumatique
stress disord de Poutine.
Ouais, ça c'est de la pure suputation.
parce que à mon avis le le le choc
émotionnel et la catatonie émotionnelle
sur un mec qui a été formé par les
services de renseignement,
à mon avis, il doit savoir quand même
gérer les phénomènes d'isolement.
Mais on peut-être, mais on est d'accord
quand on le voit, c'est pas le même
homme.
Non, mais il a l'air fâché. Il a l'air
fâché. Il a l'air coursé. Il se il se
conduit comme un personnage d'un film de
gangster quoi. C'est alors qu'avant il
faisait attention. Peut-être qu'il
l'était en privé mais là il y a la télé.
Le mec il se conduit comme s'il était
dans les soprano. C'est très bizarre
enfin.
Ça va être compliqué. Un autre pôle
géopolitique genre l'Irak, comment ça va
? Tout va bien ? L'Amérique a apporté la
paix, la démocratie, les écoles pour les
petites filles, ça s'est bien passé.
C'est c'est cool. Non, c'est toujours
pas le cas. Irak
Ah bah, ils sont retirés. C'est dommage.
Qu'ils ont toujours pas l'électricité.
C'est un truc qui me sidère quand même.
Mais
ça me sidère. Je suis arrivé en 2003,
première fois que je mets les pieds en
Irak, c'est le jour où Bagdad tombe et
donc je suis dans les rues et les gens
me disent "On a plus d'eau, on a plus
d'électricité."
Et je me dis "Ouais bon bah c'est
normal, ils ont bombardé des centrales,
le temps de rebrancher et cetera et puis
après j'y suis allé en gros minimum une
fois par an tout le temps." Et à chaque
fois les gens me disaient "On a de
l'électricité pendant 2h et puis ça
s'arrête pendant 6h puis on a une
demi-heure d'électricité puis ça
s'arrête puis" et en fait ils arrivaient
pas à stabiliser l'électricité. Donc et
et là, je lisais un papier bah hier où
en fait il y a toujours des problèmes de
stabilité d'électricité dans une ville
comme Bagdad. Donc c'est on est quand
même là, on va être quasiment 19 ans
après l'invasion. C'est c'est un truc
hallucinant quoi. C'est bon
ça ça va faire un bon terr
que l'État se casse la gueule qui a plus
de service public, qui a plus
d'électricité, qui a plus d'eau chaude.
Les ça va faire bien pour recruter pour
les extrémistes. Non. Oui. Alors moi je
je il y a il y a des enfin tu sais j'ai
été à depuis qu'on s'est vu, je j'ai
fait un truc qui m'a beaucoup intéressé.
J'ai couvert la bataille de Raka
du côté des des brigades internationales
qui combattaient auprès des YPG là des
Kurdes. C'est une histoire qui était un
peu dure à raconter parce que les accès
étaient pas faciles euh les curd des
temps très parano. Euh a raison.
Et a raison.
Ouais. Euh et euh le truc dingue c'est
que Daesh, puisque tu parles de ça,
enfin quand tu dis recruter, tu parles
de ça, ben c'était un mouvement très
international en fait. C'est-à-dire que
les combattants qu'il y avaient en face,
c'était quasiment tous des étrangers. B
il y avait des Syriens, il y avait des
Irakiens, il y en avait pas mal, hein.
Mais ça représ Raka représentait une
sorte de force d'attraction qui menaient
tous les mecs euh euh qui avaient un un
p au casque, quoi. Euh et en même temps
qui se sentaient parce que c'est souvent
des mecs de quartier, des mecs qui se
sentent pas voulus, pas intégrés,
rejetés, racisés, enfin tout ça et qui
choisissaient un endroit symbolique
parce que c'était ça jouait beaucoup sur
l'image d'Aesh. joue toujours beaucoup
sur l'image où tu vas gagner une sorte
de puissance. Ça c'est un c'est un power
trip en fait Daesh et et et ça attiré
énormément de gens qui étaient en
situation de de de d'impuissance sociale
et d'impuissance politique totale. Et
donc ouais, c'est ça. C'était une sorte
de machin de de qui brillait là comme le
le rage de Milan et et qui a cessé de
briller en octobre en octobre 2017 quand
quand Raka est tombé.
Question internet.
Paul Morera, sa-il pourquoi Glenn
Greenwald, un grand journaliste
brésilien, a quitté The Intercept du
jour au lendemain puisqu'il parl bien de
ce média ? Je alors je sais qu'il s'est
fâché sur un texte qui avait été réécrit
parce que c'est un des fondateurs, il
est pas brésilien, il est américain,
enfin il est il vit au Brésil mais
dans mon souvenir, il s'est fâché sur un
texte qui a été réécrit. C'est en fait
c'est c'est ce qu'il a communiqué en
tout cas. Euh Glenn Greenwald, il est il
est assez étonnant. Moi, je je je
respecte beaucoup ce journaliste.
Il est assez volcanique, il est assez
émulsif comme ça. Il est il
se fâche un peu avec tout le monde et je
sais pas exactement
ce qu'il a ce qui s'est passé avec la
direction de d'Intercept. Mais il y a un
moment où il s'est senti là par exemple
il il a tendance à prendre la défense de
Fox par exemple parce qu'il dit que euh
sur les chaînes conservatrices
finalement on entend une parole plus
libre que sur certaines chaînes
libérales. Euh il est il aime beaucoup
le paradoxe, il aime beaucoup aller à
contre-courant. Donc je suis pas du tout
dans le secret des dieux. Je sais pas
exactement ce qui s'est passé mais je
crois me souvenir de ça.
Question internet. Pourquoi le monde
diplôme n'est jamais cité, jamais invité
sur les plateaux malgré leurs articles
qui font pourtant référence ?
C'est une bonne question. Moi, je ne
dirige pas une émission de plateau, mais
si j'en dirigeais une, je je les
inviterai aussi souvent que possible
parce qu'effectivement, il y a il y a il
y a à la fois c'est un point de vue fort
et souvent très documenté. Je ne sais
pas euh faudrait vérifier hein. Je ne
sais pas si euh ils acceptent de venir
si facilement que ça.
Oh, ça va être facile. On va les
appeler. Et on arrive à la fin. Est-ce
que tu veux rajouter quelque chose ? Tu
as envie de parler de méia crash encore
? Est-ce que tu veux mettre plus de
détails ?
Ah, moi je crois que c'est un film bah
qui vaut la peine d'être vu parce que
c'est euh tu l'as vu donc ça t'a
intéressé. Oui, oui,
je pense que euh
c'est aussi l'apparition de la
possibilité de faire de l'enquête vidéo
télévisé en dehors d'une chaîne de télé.
Euh nous c'est la première fois qu'on
travaille comme ça d'ussi près avec avec
Media Part qui est aujourd'hui le la
grande puissance du journalisme
numérique et bon je j'ai des des amitiés
évidemment avec forme de journalistes de
Médiapart et je leur dis souvent là au
point où vous en êtes, vous devriez
développer beaucoup plus la vidéo. Euh
donc je je je pense que ça enfin il y a
un futur qui peut s'ébaucher là. Alors,
je je complète ta réponse. Nous, on va
bientôt prendre le million d'abonnés sur
YouTube. Si un jour tu as inviton
de de 175
très fort, on te propose de diffuser
chez nous sans aucun problème.
D'accord. Ben merci.
Et continue, je t'ai coupé. Non mais je
voilà, je je pense que c'est un c'est un
film qui préfigure peut-être ça, cette
ce nouveau courant quoi, de que Internet
accueille des films que d'habitude tu ne
verrais qu'à la télévision. Parce que
généralement internet pour des raisons
de fric quoi, c'est plutôt des
interviews parce que tu vois, enquêter 4
ou 5 mois à deux ou trois personnes sur
un truc, ça coûte beaucoup d'argent
quoi.
Ça coûte combien ? Genre 500000 € ?
Ah non, quand même pas.0000. Non, ça
coûte 100000 €.
100000 € ?
100000 € ? Ouais.
Combien de personnes ? trois personnes
euh trois personnes et un mois un mois
de montage un mois et demi de montage.
Donc bon euh c'est à la fois beaucoup
d'argent et je peux te dire que par
rapport au standard américain, c'est
peanuts. Donc avec un peu d'aide du
public, avec un peu de fond, on a tous
mis un peu de notre poche, nous on a mis
de notre poche médi amis de sa mais on
voulait vivre cette expérience là, se
dire est-ce que en dehors des canaux
officiels, même ce que je respecte, he
je pense que le service public français,
faut le saluer, ce qui est en train de
se passer est quand même vachement bien.
complément d'enquête, cache
investigation, envoyé spécial, c'est des
émissions dans lesquelles tu vois des
vrais sujets courageux euh que vraiment
dont ils peuvent être très fiers quoi.
Mais c'est très peu comme on disait tout
à l'heure, c'est finalement un espace
très réduit mécaniquement. Donc le
l'idée c'est ça quoi, c'est de se dire
est-ce que et c'est là où moi je
trouvais ça explorateur. J'aime bien
j'aime bien les trucs explorateurs,
j'aime bien euh aller en première ligne
et découvrir des trucs et expérimenter
des trucs. Et je c'est la conversation
qu'on avait avec les gens de Mediaapart.
On se disait au fond, on peut faire
exister qu'on ne pourrait pas voir à la
télévision parce que on met en danger
trop d'intérêt parce que je sais pas
moi, par exemple là, on a un projet avec
Olivier Besancno euh qui veut et je
parle des Kurdes quoi parce qu'il lui il
est pote avec les Kurdes depuis
longtemps pour des raisons humaines,
pour des raisons politiques, pour et il
il était venu nous voir en disant "Mais
moi je veux faire un film qui montre
qu'on les trahit ces gens-là, qui montre
que
on les a laissé crever, hein. C'est crev
sous les bombes turques parce que quand
même si on parle d'un pays de l'OTAN,
celui-là qui envahit un autre pays et
qui tue des civils, la Turquie,
bienvenue, personne personne ne s'est
offusqué. Enfin, je veux dire, c'est moi
je suis allé sur tous les plateaux en
disant c'est dégueulasse en vraiment en
parlant comme un chartier parce que
j'étais mais outré par enfin les Turcs
ils nous ont sauvé la Cen quoi à Raka
c'était eux qui avançaient la nuit en
marchant sur des œufs. Chaque porte
était minée. Enfin c vraiment ils ont
risqué leur vie pour pour pas pour nous
pour une certaine idée de liberté.
Kurd les Kurdes
c'était c'était pas les Turcs qui
avançaient à pas, c'était les Kurdes.
Bien sûr, j'ai dit les Turcs, je suis
désolé, je voulais dire les Kurdes.
Merci de me reprendre. Donc enfin,
Besantnowno vient donc avec un projet de
film en disant "Bah, j'ai envie de voilà
de parler de ça. On il y a des escadrons
de la mort qui viennent tuer des
activistes kurdes euh en Europe. Euh euh
personne dit rien." Enfin voilà, j'ai
envie de raconter un truc là-dessus et
moi, je trouve ça intéressant d'avoir ce
mec euh qui a une personnalité
politique. Je sais pas, c'est comme
Ruffin ou qui a un truc à dire, qui veut
le dire avec un film. Bah, je trouve que
c'est un objet intéressant. On peut lui
donner la parole. Bah, je sais pas moi,
l'extrême droite, elle a table ouverte
partout. en ce moment sur toutes les
télévisions. Bah que de temps en temps
de l'eau de bord, il y a un mec qui a un
petit espace, ça se conçoit en fait.
Là, je vais me faire l'avocat du diable.
Et ben, on a eu alors je te finis le
truc, on a eu que des noms, on a eu que
des négatifs partout et dans les chaînes
que j'aime et que je respecte le service
public, que des noms parce que malaise
avec Olivier Besno, je suppose.
À mon avis, c'est surtout malaise avec
les Kurdes.
Non, non, non, pas du tout. Non, il y a
eu plein de films sur les curdes. Oui.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
La droite à boulevard partout. Là,
j'entends des trucs sur internet à
longueur de journée. France inter, c'est
les gauchistes. Il y a des gauchistes
partout. Les journalistes, c'est les
écoles de gauchistes. Il nous pont des
petits gauchistes, il y a des gauchistes
partout.
C'est vrai, c'est pas vrai que la presse
française, elle a tendance à avoir un
point de vue qui s'arrange avec
l'idéologie.
C'est évident que chez les chez les
journalistes, tu as
ça a dû être calculé hein, mais tu as
une majorité de gens qui votent à la
gauche ou écolo. C'est
l'inverse de la police, c'est ça
l'inverse de la police. J'avais jamais
pensé ça comme ça, mais probablement euh
c'est probable que quand tu as 16 ans et
que tu te dis je trouve le monde
injuste, je trouve que le rapport
dominant dominé bah il devrait être
questionné. Je trouve que on devrait se
battre contre la corruption. Je trouve
queon devrait se battre contre le les
grandes multinationales qui font rien
contre le réchauffement climatique et
cetera. Tout ça c'est des thèmes qu'on
peut juger être gauchisant ou moi je le
vis comme un contrepouvoir. Je pense que
les journalistes
quand tu veux être journaliste, c'est
parce que tu veux questionner le
pouvoir. C'est et et tu es un élément
indispensable à une démocratie. C'est
que le jour où il y a pas des emmerdeurs
qui disent "Ouais, ouais, non mais
attendez, vous baratinez là, vous dites
que vous faites des trucs mais en
réalité euh quand on check votre
discours, ben en fait c'est c'est pas du
tout ça colle pas quoi. Euh si tu as pas
cet élément-là qui est un élément un peu
perturbateur mais qui est surtout un
élément de contrepouvoir, tu as pas de
démocratie et donc on peut les appeler
de gauche. Enfin, moi ça m'est arrivé
euh moi qui suis perçu comme journaliste
sûrement de gauche. Enfin, moi je vote
d'ult gauche d'ultra gauche.
[grognement]
Moi je c'est marrant parce que je vote
écolo mais bon je j'ai pas de problème à
dire pour qui je vote. Euh
[raclement de gorge] si si tu as pas cet
élément-là dans une société qui a un
élément de contrepouvoir,
bah s'appelle une dictature quoi.
Trois bouquins et un conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Ah trois bouquins. Alors, j'ai je parlé
de bouquins qui sont des plaisirs de
lecture.
Euh
c'est joli plaisir de lecture.
Ouais. Des trucs où vraiment qui m'ont
changé euh
la route sur
The Road.
Ouais. Euh Cormac McCarty. Ça ça calme.
Ah oui, ça c'est le livre qui est il y a
un avant et un après hein. Ouais. La fin
la fin elle est dure hein.
Ouais, c'est terrible. Mais c'est un
vraiment un livre qu'il faut lire.
surtout c'est un livre qui au fond
métabolise enfin pas métabolise
métaphorise plutôt le ce qui se passe
là.
Voilà ce qui se passe là c'est une sorte
de don lookup en bouquin vraiment faut
le lire. Euh Tony Morrison que je tiens
pour la plus grande écrivain du 20e
siècle euh en terme de langue et de de
[grognement]
Beloved, c'est son plus beau livre.
Et puis
les mémoires du feu qui est une trilogie
de Eduardo Galiano sur l'Amérique latine
qui parle en manière littéraire de
de comment ce continent a été saigné.
parle pas des fuegiens. Si fuegiens, tu
sais les les habitants de terre de feu
sûrement parce que c'est des petites
c'est des petites scénettes qui sont
tout authentiques et qui sont vachement
bien.
La dernière représentante
qui parlait cette langue est morte cette
année. Ouis.
Un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Ah [__] sauvez-nous.
On va te on va te laisser crever vieux.
Sauvez-nous. Non, mais je dis ça parce
que l'autre jour, je suis allé en
Allemagne, je fais un et euh j'ai filmé
euh une manive de gamin, mais vraiment
pour moi c'était des enfants hein, mais
euh
Fridays for Future. Non non, ils avaient
16 ans, tu vois. C'est le truc de Greta
Tomberg euh et des jeunes allemands, de
gamins quoi qui ont envahi le un lieu
qui est une mine de charbon à ciel
ouvert qui
difficile pour les flics de leur taper
dessus parce que 16 ans taper un mineur.
Impossible. Impossible. Impossible. Et
puis les flics allemands sont moins
violents que le que que les flics
français globalement. Et donc ils sont
ils sont passés et c'était étonnant
parce que c'est une mine et c'est la
mine qui produit le plus de charbon euh
en Europe. C'est c'est un trou de 2 km
de long
qui exproprie le plus.
Ouais. Il cassent des villages pour
faire pour continuer leur trou tout ça.
[grognement] Et je les ai trouvé
enthousiasm ces gamins. Donc voilà le
conseil de que je donne au jeunes
génération c'est sauver nous
Paul Morera et Louis Plenel. Merci.
Coup.
[musique]